the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion at the sinkfield cup in
St Louis it's official we have a new
Champion with Fabiano caruana clinching
the title but there is plenty left to
play for with the sinkfield cup and its
incredible prize fund still up for grabs
players must have been in a wild west
mood because there were quick draws
every everywhere co-leader lenar
Dominguez hoped to gain some ground but
was unable to get any traction settling
for half a point we're all tied up with
the cup on the line the final round of
the 2023 sinkfield Cup coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round n of the singfield cup
it has been an amazing tournament and
let's enjoy the final round together
let's go back to the studio and get
[Music]
started hello and welcome and it's the
final day of the sinkfield cup and guess
what there is a two-way tie for first
place place but five players remain in
contention whatever happens today A
sinkfield Cup winner will be crowned I'm
International Master Yanka housea and as
always it's a great pleasure to be
commentating all the action alongside
these two very clever Grandmasters Y
sarahan and Peter Sidler Joy it's a
pleasure to be with you Peter as well
it's been a great tournament it really
is but it's Championship round
everything's going to end today hello
everyone and Welcome to our live
coverage indeed this is it this is the
final round of the 2023 Singo cup and as
Joy has been saying we will be crowning
a champion will it be Fabby putting an
exclamation mark on a stellar year will
it be the Wild Card lanir Dominguez
spoiling the party will the improbable
happen by way Ty for first lots to talk
about Joy do the honors tell our viewers
the standings absolutely and let's check
out the final stand well not the final
standings the standings after round
eight and here we can see it's a two-way
tie between Fabiana Carana and lenia
Dominguez both players on four and a
half points out of seven someone else
who is on four and a half points is wle
so but he has played eight games because
of Y Kristoff's duda's withdrawal after
round two so that means his tournament
is over but all he can do is sit and
wait and find out which place he will
finish on after today's games precisely
and what about our grand chestor
standings
absolutely and there we can see Fabiano
Carano went into the sful cup with 33
Grand chestor points he was virtually a
short of first place and of course he's
leading the competition with plus two
which means that he has won the grand
chest but there is a big battle in
finding out who will finish in in second
and third place between Maxim Vash and
perhaps Wesley so our format Joy mhm and
uh the players are playing a 10-player
round robin at a classical time control
of 90 minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and
then a 30 second incent from move one
and my favorite part no draw offers
allowed biting chess assured but we
talked about it there's a possibility of
playoff tell us what happens in case of
the playoff what's the format yeah well
things will get dramatic and
nerve-wracking at the same time if two
players are tied for first today then it
will be decided by a two game rapid
match the time control of 15 minutes
plus 10 seconds per move if there are
three or more players tied for first
then it will all be decided by a blitz
round robin 10 minutes plus 5 seconds is
their shorter time control and and if
things are still not decided after this
playoff well then everything and I mean
everything will be decided by armagedon
where white will have 5 minutes on the
clock black will have four minutes but
black does get draw odds and no time is
added what whatsoever but I tell you one
thing if playoffs happen they happen
today outstanding looking forward to
that in case of a playoff and there we
have it our grand Chester Champion
Fabiano entering the tournament Hall as
he's getting ready to do battle in the
final round Peter lots of potential
scenarios for you to talk about
absolutely there there's still a lot to
discuss in both the the singfield cup of
course and also the the winner of the
grand chest tour for for this year has
been decided but there's a lot to play
for second and third qualifiers will
play in the next year's tour which is a
great very very important deal to a lot
of these players we've seen it in
interviews so let's take a look at the
standings and talk about some of those
uh details as you have already seen
these are the standings before the all
important ninth round uh only three
players are about 50% Wesley so is done
he's finished all eight games and today
he gets to be a spectator whereas for
Fabiano in L year there's a it seems
like a straight shootout for first
although if both of them were to lose we
could enter some very very exciting
territory and uh let's take a look at
how they got here this is the only
player with the entirety of his lines
score filled out as you can see there
two very nice victories in rounds four
and six against reard rort and the very
very nice technical game against lean
onion but a bad loss against Fabiano
Kanan in round seven uh derailed feels
like derailed his title uh Chase and he
he made a quickish draw yesterday
finishing on four and a half out of uh
eight next one up is uh lenier Dominguez
who started by making four draws and
then a very important Victory with black
against Anish giri which uh we will also
be talking about the cand qualification
there was a seismic event in that
respect and then a victory against
Richard raport draw yesterday plays
Black against his neighbor Leon aronian
today and the men of the year not the
men of the aara the men of the Year
Fabiano Carana very very nice tournament
for him four draws then a res day then a
buy and then he won two in a row very
very uh exciting game with black against
alira and then he beat Wesley draw
yesterday plays uh Richard rort who is
TI for last today with the white pieces
you would assume he is a slight favorite
before the the round
begins yes uh and all of that uh the two
games that we will be watching I think
with the most interest are the St Louis
Derby so to speak between Leon aronian
and Lenard Dominguez in which uh leevon
historically slightly ahead with with a
5-3 score in decisive games and 15
draws so that's definitely one to one
watch and the other one is the aention
game between uh Fabiano Carana who leads
the tournament and Richard raport who is
not really doing all that well in the
tournament far fewer games within them
than in the previous matchup but Fabi is
once again ahead 3-1 with uh seven draws
and there you see you see them on your
screen getting getting ready for for the
tournament very important pregame ritual
of making sure every piece is exactly
correct and the happiest part of my day
in introducing woman Grand Master
Anastasia carich with all the chess news
welcome
welcome thank you P it's an honor for me
to be introduced by you all these days
thank you so much for that and hello
everyone it's really hard to believe we
have the last round today and it feels a
little bit sad actually that the
tournament is going to be finished today
um I'm here for you waiting for the
players when they come here and give
their interviews after the end of the
games I'm also taking care of social
media accounts together with G toonova
please follow our account St Louis chess
club and Grand chest tour to get more
information more insights um let me
remind you about some news which
happened today uh today we have actually
the birthday of former world champion
Magnus Carlson let's congratulate him he
has the 3 to3d um um year of his life
and actually 2023 was really successful
for him he managed to win uh two events
of Gras tour in Poland and Croatia you
can see on the next picture if we will
see it how he's celebrating his victory
9 out of nine in this event and um in
2016 Magnus Carlson managed to win the
World Championship match on his birthday
and U the second post I wanted to pay
attention is the post from yesterday
where we can see the players chatting uh
with each other after the end of the
games we know the two games finished
simultaneously Anish giri Fabiano
caruana um Wesley and Yan she were
chatting and speaking about the sports
in the candidates tournament um in a
very nice and friendly atmosphere it's
really great to see
players after the games when they have
time also to speak with each other and
then we also of course we also see them
fighting during the rounds so it was a
really nice moment and our brilliant
photographer lonard Otis have made all
those photos and now round nine is about
to start let's go back to the studio
thank you Ania yeah I love all that
social media Stu I know and I love it
when the players are getting together
and working out all the possible
permutations of who will qualify for the
feed day candidates who will perhaps win
this event we're going to find out tell
our viewers what they can expect in the
pairings for this Championship round
this could get very spicy now we did
mention it's possible for there to be a
five-way tie for this to happen yashi
needs to to beat Anish giri with the
white pieces Maxim Vash gra also needs
to win against Ali Raa fua for leevon
ronian he also there on three and a half
points needs to get up to the golden
four and a half points by beating lenia
Dominguez and Fabiano caruana takes on
Richard report and Richard is the one
who needs to win with the black pieces
and wisely so he does not play today
cheering all of that yes he has the buy
but he already has four and a half
points out of eight as we see the
players getting ready and Chris bird uh
the chief Arbiter giving the last
instructions uh probably to do with the
playoffs as well and
uh well play underway Showtime yes sir
it really is but uh just before we get
into the showtime uh the players have
been fighting very very hard uh Joi what
are they fighting for tell us about the
prize money it's a Beau beautiful number
here on our screens first place wins
$100,000 as well as those golden Grand
chest to points second place 65,000
48,000 for third place and even there's
a substantial amount of money for player
who finishes last exactly and uh Peter
told us about the two Marquee uh games
that we're going to witness the the one
between Fabby as white against Richie
now Richie Just had a horrible outing in
the king's Indian defense against Wesley
so and I don't think Wesley sitting in
his hotel room would be very happy if
Richie was to play a king's Indian what
will he play Peter you'll never know
I an honest answer or at least an honest
answer if we consider uh Richard of old
yes before he became a much more solid
well-rounded player who plays Mainline
openings but him actually sort of
staring at the screen there or staring
just off into into a distance here is
maybe an indication that something
quirky might might come because if you
want to play E6 you will play six much
faster than it has been uh not not
played so far right uh we'll see uh I
will just say that uh Fabio apparently
didn't get the memo cuz he is the only
player not playing one E4 today there
will be open positions in every every
other game but Fabi is sticking to his
idea of playing D4 C4 it brought him
great success in all important game
against Wesley so where he was
absolutely winning by move 13ish in a in
a nimzo which really doesn't happen very
often and must be a a welcome sign for
for anybody while the rest of the
players seem to be moving along Richard
as you mentioned kind of stering off in
the distance uh just tell our viewers
what he might be thinking about Kings
Indian already mentioned yeah Kings
Indian is well okay we we now have a
have an A slav A slav but in a move
order which I think generally is
considered to be somewhat inferior to
the classical my feeling is maybe
specifically because of Bishop F4 D5 and
E3 or at least that was always my
understanding that this is the reason
you don't want to be playing uh the slav
in this particular move order because uh
what that allows is for white to play
positions which are maybe spiritually
close to The Exchange love but without
exchanging the pawns on D5 which of
course is you preserve the option but
you you don't you're not committing to
it yet but Fabby very quickly says no
I'm okay with just playing the the
classical variations goes Knight F3 and
now we're assuming C6 is going to be
followed by D5 you can still switch to
some very very suboptimal stuff with
the6 but I hope he doesn't do that right
um and
suboptimal did you just throw an insult
out
there yes I mean if if you compare the
slav to the the old Indian which which
is what you will get after I'm assuming
you play D6 with the intention of
playing this
you kind of have to feel in particular
in the age where everybody analyes
within you feed this to the engine it
will immediately give white like plus
one
by it's not maybe all that bad but still
it's it's it's on our screen right now
that it's maybe not not the greatest
opening in the world D5 Knight C3 in the
meantime played curious as to what uh
suits Richard the best in this position
because options are extremely wide
actually you can go for the chebanenko
positions with A6 he's already played E6
Bishop F5 is playable DT C4 is of course
the main move and has been for the
longest time uh
and I would think that he probably would
like at least a chance to somewhat you
know redeem his tournament by by playing
a fighting game today and in that
respect I thought maybe the Cheno some
of the quirkier things after d takes C4
were maybe a better shot but he goes for
E6 I very quickly says no to the Moscow
anti Moscow no to the binic variation
just a classical uh Morano or anti Moran
depending on what he does after the
expected move night B7 which is by far
the most popular here so which one after
Knight B D7 is more popular moving the
queen to C2 or Bishop to D3 because I
always found Bishop to D3 the trickier
opening to handle Bishop D3 is old
school Queen C2 karpov really kind of I
think Bishop D3 is becoming the meta
once again because it it felt to me that
it was extremely popular maybe in the
mid90s there were a lot of theore
discussions there was the famous game
between Kasparov and kramnik even which
kramnik won I think in DOS manes in the
mid 90s and then I think people switch
to Quincy 2 because people thought why
do I need to study all this extremely
sharp stuff which uh sometimes in
particular if black goes with the A6
lines here E4 C5 and you get these
absolutely uh fantastic variations after
both D5 and D5 then there was maybe a
Resurgence when vishan used this line
with black with great success in the
bond match against scrum niik right
where he went and that was kind of an
early precursor of the modern approach
where I think vishy he won two games
with black in that line and I think both
times he went for lines which he knew
are unbelievably risky against best play
right but he felt he was the better
prepared player right and he felt that
the risk is worth it because if Vlad
doesn't know exactly how it's refuted
it's going to be extremely difficult to
refute over the board right and it it
paid off yeah but yeah these positions
are very very tricky to navigate whereas
if you play Queen C2 you probably don't
achieve very much but you also run
almost no initial risks you will get to
move 15 with a very stable position
where subtle intricacies of positional
play will matter but no serious cost to
any single move uh you're reminding me
of uh a candidate's game I played with
Michael Tall I literally had spent a
month uh working on these uh Morano
positions after Knight B8 to D7 with uh
my coaches uh we were having a lot of
fun analyzing these positions and I came
very proudly to the board I played my
move Bishop D3 and Misha played against
me a move I had never
seen literally before and probably since
he just played the move Bishop B4 and it
was just so absolutely annoying here was
one of my 30 minute thinks you know and
uh I I didn't get an advantage out of
the opening and I I'm just wondering is
it on your database Bishop B for JY uh
Bishop Knight B8 D7 D7 Bishop D3 D3 and
now Bishop yes how many uh I'm I'm
actually eagerly looking at this because
any type of shortcut against the
complications I'm you take a look at
yeah you I mean Gary casparo faced it
against Robert hubner back in 1986
wow I
mean my candidat 1985 was when Michael
to played it have you ever faced Bishop
I don't really play the classical Maron
with white so I wouldn't have had an
opportunity and when there was a brief
moment when I was including this as my
part of my repertoire with white but for
the at that point my idea was very much
to play Queen C2 and then to play the
shabal of a exactly G4 which that was
maybe the early 2000s it hasn't really
been analyzed
as completely as it feels to have been
analyzed by now it felt playable I even
then you kind of knew you're not really
going to be better if black reacts
properly but it was a very fun position
very fresh position to analyze so I had
this a couple of times uh but yeah the
the classical Bishop D3 I have almost
never played I think tell us about uh
Lanier's uh position Peter because that
is our co-leader as well yeah this one
began as uh linear here trying to play
the Berlin left saying no D2 D3 move
four Bishop C5 castles interestingly
here uh L decides not to play kn9 D4
which I feel is still the best move in
the POS or at least the most popular
move in this position people generally
just play 9 D4 here and after takes
takes C3 Bishop B6 there have been
attempts to fine-tune this for white to
get something but okay yeah the old
Richard is back today excellent uh
uh you can do some really strange stuff
here for instance Bishop A4 SES like
playing it before it even gets chased
with by C6 is somehow something people
do but normally you play something like
Knight A3 C6 Bishop A4 let's say D6 the
Knight comes to C4 and if white were in
time to first off S step the fork play F
F2 F4 in a in a good spot he would be a
bit better but black obviously always
has something to say about that but
instead of all of those uh D6 was played
by lineer uh Knight C3 Knight C3 played
by Leon I think the intention here is to
go Knight A4 yeah I had this with white
wi different move orders uh this
position is I think it's fine for black
but you can definitely uh have a little
bit of a bite if black doesn't play uh
entirely precisely one kind of a quirky
variation here is Knight D4 Knight C5
Knight B5 and now we go with with our KN
hanging we continue chasing this one
down I had this against Vladimir Kik
once with
with the white pieces uh it's a bit
better for white it's it's nothing
particularly special but it's a bit
better for white generally I think is is
the feeling and let's briefly return the
reason I kind of went went a bit wow
there yes is Richard played D6 waited
for the movie 2 E3 and then played G6
this is very much don't don't try this
at home territory well uh I I had
included because of my match with kpof
the schlecter slav into my
repertoire in those days um E2 E3 was
what anatol karov played exclusively so
I I didn't have to worry about the
Knight C3 variation but G7 G6 Knight
C3 Bishop G7 Bishop D3 is how our games
went and I would never have considered
the move E7 E6 in that spe activ
counterproductive about the schle yeah
one of the major major ideas for black
in all of these types of positions and
gakamsky I guess these days is by far
the main proponent of this for black you
always want to get rid of this bishop
and then play7 you very very happily
snap on F3 the moment the opportunity
presents itself right and then you play
the structure which is actually with the
bishop gone from behind the chain not
bad is very solid yes very and you also
get this type of structure with E6 but
in in certain variations where you've
won the bishop path say for instance I'm
thinking of I can't remember what it's
called though the very very sharp ones
but okay the eporn has gone though I
think in those kind of positions uh I'm
thinking yeah you know the M I think
it's come us the Moscow right yeah in
the MOs in the MOs you also do this you
do this type of but this is this is very
important to get that get so important
in fact that one of the main moves in
this position is H3 just do not let this
happen happen at all right so the idea
of
maybe maybe bishop D3 H3 is the more
popular one but all of them exist trying
to keep it on C8 right and here uh
Richard is playing playing the schle
tempo down and honestly I would argue
maybe passing would be better than6 in
this position
A6 vastly vastly Superior to to to E6
but this kind of approach can work if
you're playing an extremely aggressive
opponent and you're just basically say
come get me I'm just going to wait for
you to seize the initiative in the
center and then you know the bishop on
G7 but bearing in mind that
Fabiano doesn't necessarily have to go
all in to win yeah I'm not sure about
the waving a a red flag in Fr of Fabby
uh first of all does the move E7 E6
exist in our database yes it does it's
been played how many times been played
before and actually has quite a few big
names playing it so uh Lazaro BRZ
from played
it Nei the grandm from India has also
played it as has yuang y this was in
2011 one of their attempts to refute E7
E6 I I don't know if we can actually the
way to try and really refute it would be
to play something like B3 with the
intention of meeting Bishop G7 with
Bishop A3 but you have to contend with
Queen A5 you'll have to make a slightly
awkward move Queen C1 the engine likes
even this to be honest I was worried
about Knight E4 but it says now we will
quite happily play B4 and we will be uh
better here you can definitely consider
playing B3 but I think in Practical
terms for Fabby he clearly did not
expect this nobody nobody ever expects
this right so you're not going to uh not
get an advantage if you just play kind
of simple chess like we Castle they
Castle we play and on B3 here right put
the bishop on A3 now you play Queen C2
and once again this is not unplayable
for black I'm guessing if if if I were
to try and figure out how black will try
to solve the problems here you play
Knight bd7 you probably play B6 Bishop
B7 you try to play C6 C5 if all of that
happens while white is still fuing about
on the on the back rank black is
probably okay right but white can play
more more energetically you can put the
bishop on E3 you can push for E34 E3 E4
breaks you can also prepare for B7 B6
because now your knight D5 is strong you
can also definitely consider taking on
D5 because cd5 Knight B5 BAS basically
just loses uh so black will be obliged
to take with this pawn and this
structure is not always great although
it's playable it's not uh once again I
should maybe scale down the you know my
my disapproval of this this is not going
to lose a game for black or at least not
not immediately out of the opening it's
just that this is clearly something you
do to avoid playing a theoretical game
against somebody who you feel is
probably better prepared than you are
right and just to get a game by move 15
by also yeah Bishop D3 Bishop G7 in the
meantime on the board you you're trying
to get a new Fresh position probably
neither of you have seen by move 15
right very likely that uh Richie will
get that the big question have after
playing Bishop D3 the big question for
me is can we just play4 here yeah and
now the answer seems to be this is not
that bad because black can try playing
for the c65 break I still think this
should be quite seriously better for
white like a rook e one I don't know
night D7 Bishop G5 I want to play Queen
D2 Bishop H6 of course C5 D5 is always
going to be quite Pleasant E5 is maybe
the preferred Pawn break but even this
position doesn't look very safe you're
quite far behind in development right it
seems to be borderline playable but it's
also quite clearly very very risky um
all of this is kind of a welcome sign
because we're not going to get a boring
game for sure but Richard is definitely
taking uh significant risks on board
today uh before we look at the other two
boards uh let's just update our game
between leavon and lanir again we have a
uh Berlin with D3 uh Bishop C5 castles
uh I I will Echo the words of Peter I've
always felt that Knight D4 is absolutely
the go-to move here and equalizes
comfortably L went for D7 D6 the move
Knight C3 is a kind of a statement I'm
uh looking to win the two Bishop Bishops
there he goes uh with the move Knight A4
yes you're welcome to win the two
Bishops please capture on B6 and open up
my Rook okay well I'll pause for the
moment C2 C3 Joy um lots of gains from
this position very theoretical dispute
still going on here yes um Magnus
Carlson has had this with the white
pieces against Wang UA and uh another
one is palat against Ian bakro has also
played this in 2018 that game was a draw
also Blast One past but I think he still
plays Kevin spagett Canadian Grand
Master
out4 right yeah we played together in
the candidates so C2 C3 uh on the board
and then the two remaining games yeah
those are uh let's start maybe with the
they're both interesting in just how
many moves they made and let's start
with the one where I can understand
what's going
on that's always a good it's a bit
easier with this one this is a game
between mvl and ala the the French
teammates once again Berlin was ventured
castles was played but not D4 so we're
playing a rook E1 which is generally
quite a uh sedate opening yes but not in
this particular variation which is
something we had in this tournament uh
the pawn sacrifice yeah the bishop F4
Pawn sacrifice we had this in that game
between Wesley so and uh Leon aronian
but after Bishop d49 D5 Leon went for
the more modern approach of playing C6
instead of D6 whereas in this game ala
says no I will actually be able to
remember what the file says and goes for
the absolute Main Line Bishop G5 F6
Bishop H4 takes on uh sorry uh G5 first
actually uh Queen E4 white needs to be
playing very very energetically and very
quickly in the center Bishop B2 Rook E1
Black Goes Bishop B5 back F4 blows
everything up obviously you can't play
Slowly here if you give black time to
start chasing a pieces away you are two
pawns down so F4 very understandable uh
takes takes D5 Bishop
D3 and black has already replyed with
Bishop F5 Queen F5 Queen takes D5 Queen
H7 King f8 the reason I'm sort of
rushing through all of this this is
still Theory even I have seen this and I
don't play it with either
color I recognize this uh this landscape
and it's it's one of the positions where
it looks very dangerous for black Rook
on A8 is currently not participating in
the defense the king seems bare
but if you if you look at it with
engines I think the engines will just
tell you this holds yeah and very often
it just ends in some kind of repetition
here queen h8 queen H7 might be one
logical repetition a move like Bishop G6
might look scary but after Queen G8 we
actually need to start going back and
just to illustrate let's say if you end
up in some kind of position like this
where black gets 96 in get gets King E7
in the r comes out black is still two
pawns up perhaps the pawn on H4 Falls
but the King on A7 also at some point
might start running towards complete
safety on C8 right you start preferring
black here so it's very understandable
that you need to be fast and it seems
that there is no way to I don't know
include the rook in the attack quickly
enough that black needs to be very
worried about it mvl has now finally
paused and is sort of considering uh
what to do
but seems like this is just a a position
they are both aiming for which I assume
is held by black with precise play but
as I said this I can at least understand
this is just a very very Mainline
Central theoretical discussion in the
Berlin well I see that Ali R has
actually gained four minutes on the
clock and mvl has only just gone gone di
below the uh the 130 mark this one I
don't understand at all okay because
this is also move 20 and we're 20
minutes into the broadcast and this
really doesn't seem forced to me uh at
all this has been an Italian uh Knight
F6 two knights were not played in this
game D3 Bishop C5 castles D6 C3 A5 Rook
E1 this is also obviously a very very
main line of an Italian right uh very
heavily discussed but
uh I don't really recognize the current
uh the current position at all I I don't
know why they got there so quickly this
idea of playing Bishop B6 uh before you
even played Rook E8 uh is a very uh kind
of a trendy approach which we discussed
during one of the earlier shows and our
conclusion was I think we both said
exactly the same thing with with yovanka
if white has pawns on B4 and A4 this is
maybe good for white this structure with
a Pawn on A5 it's generally accepted to
be completely fine with for for black I
guess Yan also agrees because he goes
Bishop B5 Queen B8 is sometimes played
in these types of positions but I think
more with the inclusion of H3 and H6 uh
here Anish goes Bishop A7 white goes
Bishop B3 the bishops come off the
board uh all of this is very logical I'm
just wondering why they've done it all
so quickly I understand sort of every
single move in isolation I understand
very much I don't understand how you can
make 20 of them in 10 in 10 minutes it's
interesting actually because uh after
black played Knight E7 yeah M and D4
happened yes there's very few games on
the database okay so there's one game
between um Michael Adams against Matt
Lov and
H5 Bishop F1 is the new move Bishop F1
H5 yeah Bishop F1 might seem strange but
it it doesn't really belong on B5 and
very often you just need it away from
squares where it can be attacked and
strangely often you actually like it on
F1 because if black manages to land the
Knight on F4 it becomes much easier to
show it away when you have the bishop P
already protecting the pawn H3 once but
yeah H5 is very confusing move to me
because it's immediately explained by
the followup but why H5 and not H6 I do
not know why it goes C3 C4 also very
understandable attempt to first of all
gain some space in the center and
secondly develop the Knight to a good
Square against instead of a kind of a
mediocre Square on D2 and Knight H7
which is why we play the H Pawn
somewhere right but y two squares and
not one I guess because Anish knows
everything is would be my guess uh
Knight C3 Knight G5 this trade happened
Rook G3 Queen H4 now the downside is you
have to pay attention to this Pawn you
maybe would have chosen a different
square but it would have been hanging
and now G5 G5 Queen
B3 Rook a B8 B6 also looks playable but
I guess Rook a B8 is slightly more
flexible and queen B5 and we finally
have them thinking on move 20 they
rushed to I'm with joy on this bishop F1
kind of a novelty normally you slow down
H5 came Alla Tempo and all of this
happened very very quickly what's the
current according to the engines at
least their prognosis who who's out
played who no not not unexpectedly this
is still around equal
although very importantly to my eyes it
seems like the engine is very much
against the idea of protecting A5 which
is surprising to me it just doesn't
doesn't suggest B6 at all and says B6
Queen C6 now you're in trouble because
I'm guessing the Knight will come to D5
C7 perennially uh vulnerable and you you
have to start to worry so its current
preferred method of playing this
position is just giving you the A5 pawn
and saying I have plenty of compensation
I've denied you the D5 Square for the
Knight I want to play Rook D2 this Rook
on G3 and this is an actual concern
this3 really doesn't doesn't look
particularly great at all right that has
one function though it keeps the knight
in check because I was looking at
positions and I was thinking I would
really love to get in F5 but you can't
do it with a rook on G3 you keeping me
in
check I mean according remember social
media ask I'm watching um
yeah a strange one seems so yeah you you
want to play Rook D2 the engine suggests
we can play Queen C7 putting some
pressure on this one and black even
drops the queen back wow to protect D5
and then go Knight F4 next move and it
suggests that you don't even need to do
anything immediate to prove you have
enough for a pawn because like currently
the the shape of the position it seems
to be aiming for is something like this
where there will not be any kind of an
immediate mate but there is this
fantastic King's Indian in spirit yeah
yeah complete grip over the dark squares
this is It's a good defensive Bishop but
it's not really doing very much uh black
has full control over the d d file D4
potentially a very good Square for this
Rook at some point you pretty much never
want to do this because then you might
actually get mated along the G file
eventually in some future right uh so a
kind of a positional Pawn sacrifice here
uh seems to be the suggested U method of
play for black Anish is finally thinking
uh we'll see how he reacts because this
is actually quite concrete just in that
final position that you did show it's
sort of like we are a pawn up but our
extra A2 Pawn doesn't really feel like
it's giving us any kind of a tilt on the
scales I mean this Rook on G3 I mean I
don't understand why what's it doing
what's it doing there so that's why I
was tempted to kind of trade it off but
uh but how easy is it to see this
positional Pawn sacrifice I mean I think
it's concrete though in the sense that
you don't want to play Rook A8 and you
don't want to play B6 well you just came
from A8 so you're choosing you're
choosing between B6 and some way of
giving up on A5 you either begin with
Rook fd8 or you begin with C6 because I
think denying why the D5 square is
actually something that everybody will
understand and you couldn't go for moves
like Rook A8 just to kind of meet Queen
takes B7 Rook B8 just came from there I
mean on the previous move maybe but
having played Rook B8 if if you want to
give me the B7 Pawn just play Rook F d8
here I would actually understand very
much but it's maybe even one of the
suggested things to do although it
doesn't specifically it kind of hates 95
so yeah okay well critical moment there
for Anish will he be tempted to defend
his porn or will he sacrifice it for
positional compensation if I can just
boldly State the obvious
13547 5 minutes and 47 seconds of bonus
time has been added to Jan's clock uh as
he's just played in total Blitz mode and
Anish finally uh stalled uh after this
this move Queen B5 um quick question for
you Peter C7 C6 on the board Queen takes
A5 expected uh Rook d8 I'm I'm no big
fan of my Rook on G3 after the move uh
Rook Rook of G you want to play G3 yeah
that's exactly what I wanted I think I
think you actually kind of get M there
right there's some
some no I didn't see the valuation but
is it simply the sacrifice you can even
go slower you can go qu 5 first
and the issue is you pretty much will be
obliged to do in some order you will
have to play King H1 Knight F4 Bishop F1
which would have been maybe acceptable
if not for the fact that Bish C C4 of
course using overloading the bishop on
F1 and things start collapsing and this
is actually like bad for white not even
not even playable beautiful trick though
I was trying to get rid of my little
clumsy Rook if you I I was also
instinctively drawn to problem solve in
that way C7 C6 on the board and Rook of
d8 is also already played Queen takes A5
Rook d8
now kind of a lonely man here as our
co-leaders all by himself in the back
room looking at the games um what do you
think Peter you've been in the situation
often enough you're tied for first going
into the last round you're in control of
your destiny but NE not necessarily the
tournament's destiny
uh are you going through these
permutations in my mind should I be
playing for a win should I be playing
for a draw what's what's going on I
think you not in the open my my I would
begin by saying not in the opening I
think like by move 30 if your position
is somewhat defined and the position of
your direct competition is also somewhat
defined you can start thinking about you
know whether I should start steering it
towards safety or perhaps I should in
fact go completely all in because my my
opposition is winning the person I'm
competing for for first but by move 10
you're playing your own game you try to
play it as well I mean you probably have
some kind of a picture of what you're
trying to achieve uh I think today L
year quite clearly went for sort of this
his normal safe repertoire he is not
trying to shake the boat too much uh
Rock the Boat not
Shake important don't tilt it over yes
uh
but yeah I think it's way too early for
for those types of strategics strategic
ideas to uh to influence your play
you're just trying to equalize with
black he's he's playing against a very
strong player you're trying to equalize
you seeing what Leon uh wants out of the
game and
then when a kind of a defining decision
perhaps presents itself like let's say
by one more 25 you have two playable
continuations one leads to a sharp sharp
tactical battle and the other one leads
to kind of a safe safe equality at that
point you do glance over at F's game and
see how f is doing and that probably
will influence your decision making but
not just yet and not for quite some time
yet I would say but on the subject of uh
last round I'd like to kind of ask you
both a question how do you deal with
nerves because there's so much on the
line here you know first prize Nets
$100,000 for a lot of people that's
lifechanging amount for me it wasn't
a100 th000 it's a
$100 so it wasn't so nerve racking as
that um for me uh I loved it I
absolutely loved it being in first place
going into the last round and I always
felt that you know playing for first
winning the tournaments is was why I was
here and I embraced it and I like to
play for a win when I was tied for first
okay I didn't like have any no I didn't
like this let's make a playoff let's
make a draw now you've won nine British
championships yourself so tell us about
your last round uh no I mean I yeah I
mean championships uh feelings and I've
only managed to successfully overcome my
nerves on certain occasions and that's
just being kind of rationalizing the you
know minimizing the result of what I'm
going to go through like for instance I
say okay don't think about the future
focus on the present I try to regulate
my breathing I do a lot of convoluted
stuff like that and uh and when I've
managed it then I managed to get in the
zone and just think and focus on the
chest
but it's it's very difficult it is a a
yeah it never bothered me no seriously
because I always felt that first of all
I mean this was something I really was
passionate about and I was really really
good at it as well so here I am doing
something I really enjoy I'm really good
at it you know why AR I embracing the
moment yeah you know and let's play for
that win and that was my my mindset and
I'm kind of withy you there a little bit
Peter like if I was in move 30 and the
position I had a choice of uh going into
a dark woods and my oppon my my
competition was winning I could see and
okay I'm going to go into the dark wood
yeah that makes decision easier because
you need to you need to continue
competing for first yes in my case I
think there were definitely some
occasions when nerves got the better of
me in these decis decisive spots but for
me I've always found that the morning
before the decisive game was completely
unbearable like I I could I could barely
sort
of like there there's these hours where
you don't know what to do with yourself
you wake up I know at 9:00 the game is
at 3: you have breakfast and then you do
some preparation but I'm I was never one
to do a lot of Prep Prep before games
and there is this unspent unspent
nervous energy that you absolutely don't
know where you know you don't know what
to do with yourself but once I I sit
down at the board
this feeling of sort of I'm doing what I
sort of am supposed to be doing this is
this is what this is what I'm trained
myself for yeah exactly this is this is
sort of the the culmination of years and
years of getting better at this right so
you guys are almost like doing a selft
talk then you're saying I've been here
before this is why I'm absolutely here
for maybe not consciously but yeah it's
definitely something that you and for me
like the moment I sit down very often
all of it will just go away now I can
sort of you control the controllables
and this is very controllable you know
it depends on me now nobody else and
I've I've worked very hard to to you
know to become good at this uh it
doesn't always work and you know there
were some occasions I still remember
with like sh you know full body Shivers
about about melting down in in front of
incredible pressure but generally for me
the the problem was always the that
period before the game and not the game
itself how did you conquer did you work
out you take a walk no you you read a
book you read a book you you watch
something on a on a screen to just kill
time but it's it's actually quite uh
refreshing when you talk to the Indian
Grand Masters in particular because they
all tell me that they well or they say
publicly that they employ performance
coaches the people who can help them
with their mental mindset in the grand
Swiss when videt won the competition we
could see him every day coming to the
board early you know he would wait with
his first move for the first like maybe
for 30 seconds 45 seconds it was like he
was visualizing the future and how he
would be behaving and dealing with any
potential upsets in the case of viit he
also attributed a little bit to working
with yoga too to get him into that uh
proper mindset by the way this move
Queen B6
Yan played Queen takes A5 Queen B6 as if
this had been on his board at breakfast
this morning I think has been really I
think it probably what guess including
H5 because that wasn't that obvious was
it it's possible it's mentioned in a
course somewhere and I'm not even joking
the idea that very strong players will
actually take a look at my course was
kind of alien to me when I recorded my
my first grvi course with chessable I
thought okay this will be aimed at Club
level players yeah I've I've hoped that
it will sort of hold up uh for very
strong players as well but I didn't
really expect them to actually invest
the time to to study and then I got some
feedback from very very strong players
saying that yeah they they found it
useful and uh and the the more chessable
expands the more it feels people are
actively aware of what the courses say
and Anisha is one of the more prolific
authors out there so perhaps perhaps you
know Yan actually knows that this is
anisha's recommendation against the
Italian you you can't entirely rule this
out so remarkable I was just thinking
has Anish done a course on this he's
done a complete one4 yes complete
with I think so yeah so there will be
there will be something against E5 it
could could could very easily be an ital
we saw an Nish took a little moment
after the move Queen B5 to play C6 he
got C6 and rook d8 in very very quickly
okay well breaking news the game between
Maxi Lov and Ali Resa fuja has finished
in a thre move repetition I'm guessing
the queen and the King just kept on
moving the queen even reference that
that type of Perpetual check has been
played uh as well and they did sorry j
yeah so a draw and what do you think
guys surprising or not
surprising because Maxim if he won right
he would be on plus one some potential
for share first place I mean if the
results go his way or maybe second place
and you know as we saw earlier on
there's a lot of prize money at stake
$100,000
65,000 and yeah
it's it petered out for him I mvl was my
pick mvl has won the singfield uh Cup
itself twice before I thought this was
going to be his uh third lucky charm he
drew every single game he played in the
tournament and I don't even think that
there was a wide margin in those games
it wasn't like he was behind minus 4 or
a head plus two or anything like that I
think his games were always he had some
sharp games but yeah they were all
fairly balanced yeah it's not yeah the
swings for instance that Jan had in some
of his white games were not present in
nbls Yeah Yeah Yeah by comparison of
kind of restrain tournament by him I
think for him today uh draw just makes a
lot of strategic sense because I think
the person who could knock him out of
the top three in the GCT standings was
alira ah and ala needed to beat him okay
so by keeping ala on one minus two and
himself on 50% as far as I understand
those permutations he just seals the
deal he gets reinvites to the tour next
year gotcha he he qualifies for the top
three of the tour and that is both in
terms of just having very strong
tournaments to play and financially of
course yeah it's it's a huge big deal
and we've we've covered the fact that he
is now rated something ridiculous not
what not at all what we're used to he is
somebody who like in my mind he's always
like 2790 exactly if not 2810 but like
mvl around the 2730 Mark makes no sense
to me whatsoever I don't yeah I don't
recognize this this world that we we
seem to be inhabiting and because of
that he is not guaranteed to get
reinvites through rating and locking up
the top three finish makes a great deal
of sense you could maybe wonder if alza
uh you know could have played sharper
could have played something that doesn't
lend itself so much to Forest draws such
as such as the Berlin but they're on
very good terms ala has had a very
forgettable tournament and perhaps he
didn't feel like playing something
extremely risky with black against
somebody who's on friendly terms with
that is very true when you do have a
poor tournament you tend to want to just
finish the last game and just get out of
that although I tend to actually do the
opposite yeah you're going to just
suffer to the what I do I kind of tell
myself okay you've had a terrible
tournament what what can I what can I do
the last thing I can do is play a game
with chess okay I don't care not the
worst thing that ever happened turn our
attention if you will Peter to the game
between Fabby and Richard because even
though we didn't necessarily like the
opening do we like the result we like it
better now we like it better now and uh
he he made a very good decision a couple
couple moves ago uh F did play E4 but
after d takes E4 uh he made it what what
is it's not a proper minor capture but I
think very very many people will just
automatically recapture with the Knight
here because two Bishops good one Bishop
bad you know why why give black an
option of taking on e4 with the Knight
but that would be a very very good thing
for white to happen because C5 KN D6
becomes a plan the whole dark Square
complex with for for black instantly
becomes very very weak so Bishop takes
E4 I was just in time to notice I do
this and think H this is very
interesting and then it was met by B5
which I think is a very very good move
and the point is this is hanging also
very importantly B5 B4 is a threat that
needs to be addressed if we take on B5
we get we get the same position but
without the pawns on C4 and C6 and the
the bishop has this whole long diagonal
to look forward to Knight has the C6
Square to look forward to this is a
completely different different scenario
comp compared to uh to this uh and f
after some thought Play Bishop D3 which
is I think a normal reaction because of
the threat of B5 before Richard took and
now I'm expecting him to play Bishop A6
which solves yet another problem that
black very often has and the one we
highlighted earlier yeah why did we play
E6 what do we what do we do with the
somewhat stupid Bishop on C8 it get it
gets traded off and it might look like
this is a poor square but it's not
really it it goes come it comes it comes
to very good squares quite
and maybe even support C6 C5 on a good
day right and also the porn on D4 very
weak as well I mean you can white can
try and argue that the porn on C6 is
also weak but uh in my experience in
these type of positions the C6 porn is
defendable whereas D4 not that easy
everything Fab's done in my estimation
is actually pretty decent I would think
that white still a tad better there may
there's maybe some some slight Advantage
left but yeah like we need or you can
you can maybe do this and try to land
this Knight on C5 so an ideal lineup
scenario here for white would be let's
make some waiting moves for both sides
yeah I H6 we go Rook e
one and one is aiming at C5 the other
one is aiming at E5 at some point D4 is
a bit vulnerable we need to figure out
what to do with the bishop on D2 but
some kind of position like this is
definitely a bit better for white this
Rook goes to C4 supporting the D4 pawn
and black does have to worry about the
pawn it's not that it gets lost it's
just that you have to invest a lot of
energy making sure it doesn't can you
immediately get rid of your C5 Pawn by
going Queen D5 in those type of
positions yeah you definitely can and
and then it becomes a fight around that
uh uh that particular topic because I
probably go B3 I put the bishop on A3 if
you get C5 successfully if yes uh if
black actually let's let's once again
make some uh really bad moves to to
illustrate a point I take black here
right Knight has a fantastic Square on
D5 even if the bishops come off it's a
bit better for black with the Bishops on
the board it is definitely a bit better
for black uh because uh the white king
queen side comes under some pressure at
least and this fantastic Square for for
the night is you can take the boy out of
the groom Feld but you can't take the
groom Feld out of the boy look at that
Bishop I was thinking the exact same
thing very true very true but but white
will definitely have something to say
about this it's either B3 or Bishop B3
we're not going to be letting C5 happen
immediately uh so it's it's still I'm
guessing a little bit better for white
but I think this is a massive
Improvement compared to the mental
picture I had of what this game will
look like somewhere somewhere around
here I actually think because of
Richard's counterplay in this particular
position well in their game position
maybe Fabby rushed E4 yeah you could
definitely have waited for for a bit you
were not obliged to do it immediately
was yeah and after after B6 you can sort
of revisit the idea of playing here but
you know funnily enough I really thought
you were explaining it very nicely
Bishop A3 Rook E8 E4 included and you
know the development the extra you know
uh piece play that white
has felt like the way to go yeah it's
not that bad for black though because
once again if you give black enough time
to play like Knight D7 followed by Queen
C7 followed by C5 it's not going to be
it's not going to be horrible but yeah
yeah Fabby I think Fabby tried for
maximum I think he thought if my early
E4 works and I you know I end up
controlling the center the way I want I
want it controlled he would be much
better but B5 is a very very good
response exactly uh JY one of the
stories uh that went along with the S
Bill cup the whole Grand chest T was
this race to get to Toronto to the
candidates and there's two ways that
some of our players could get there
either by rating or the FED Grand Prix
now that this draw has been uh made
between MBL what's our ratings watch
let's check it out because the person
with the highest rating on January the
1st 2024 will qualify according
depending on activity though for the
candidate tournaments and Wes so is
leading with 2750 7 lenia Dominguez just
one point behind him and there's Ali
Resa fua with 2750 for Ali Raza having
already made a draw with the MV uh I
mean he had the potential of gaining
five lanir potential of gaining five or
losing five Wesley he's got the buy
today so he he can't play but one rating
point for laner means he's in search of
activity requirements as well well as a
single rating point to get to the
candidates absolutely and by activity it
uh means that uh the players to qualify
in terms of highest rating they must
have played for classical tournaments I
see by the way lir coming with a very
clean shaven look today uh I just saw
him staring kind of out in space as he's
playing against leavon Aron and it was
actually funny the way Peter uh
identified that as like the grand chess
t or the world chess champion who's the
greatest chess player in the world no
the question is who's the best chess
player in St
Louis between these two neighbors leavon
and lanir uh question is an open one
Peter yeah let's take a look they're
playing you know in particular compared
to the two games one of which has
already finished they're really playing
at a snail space here they've played
nine moves Leon is almost uh down to
below an hour ler is playing faster than
leevon for now but that actually often
happens ler often starts by being faster
than his opponent right because he knows
he will start thinking once he's out of
books so he wants to you know get the
get the moves in quickly while he still
knows exactly what he's doing uh
eventually white needs to you know take
an executive decision on whether we will
be allowing black let's say to play
Knight E7 and to trade these Bishops off
the board the way to try and avoid this
is generally to do this okay uh so that
after 97 we can drop it back to
C2 one question you have to uh have
about this maneuver there's this little
uh trick that sometimes works but I
think uh specifically here the trick of
course being that we we we seem to have
blundered a piece but we haven't
actually because this is a check and
this intermediate check allows black to
recapture on7 and this
once so many pieces come off in this
structure I know it's uh kind of unusual
for me to say this but very often I
start thinking if this goes long enough
I'm going I'm going to start preferring
the side with with the Knight because
this bishop doesn't really have a lot of
uh potential one way to improve it would
be to play Queen G3 and then perhaps
immediately to play4 but if we imagine
the structure kind of solidifying I
think black has more potential for
breaks and this bishop has more
potential of not really having anything
to do whereas I will find the job for
this Knight eventually it goes to E6 or
uh there are there are good squares
available to it but very importantly
specifically now it doesn't work because
after C takes D4 Bishop takes A4 Queen
is threatened but we do have the move
B3 and after something like let's say
bish B8 I can take take and simplest is
just to play Bishop B2 black is not in
time to protect the pawn on E5 so this
just completely falls apart tactically
yeah it just doesn't work tactically
otherwise I think it would be a very
sound positional decision uh so so
that's one way to go for Leon the other
one is to make some kind of a slow
waiting move I guess H3 comes to mind
the engine suggests to move B2 B3 which
I think a human player would never ever
consider uh D3 D4 is something you
generally want but you you you once
again need to start considering Knight
takes D4 among other things same tactic
applying here right so I don't think D4
is a particularly attractive option um I
think Leon will end up there on B6 and
then either playing Bishop A4 or not but
feels like the time has come to actually
you know clarify clarify that we are
going to do the thing that's very
popular at the minute just to go B4 B4
and then just Knight takes
Bishop yeah you can you can you can do
something like this if you're in time to
play four right but because I think you
let's say we make these two moves this
is this is very unattractive right can't
do that so you have to play A4 before it
gets fixed on on the backward square but
this is another one of those positions
where honestly I prefer the knights and
do we also have to rush with uh swapping
off the light Square Bishop I think Joy
had Bishop C4 I wanted Bishop C4 you
wanted to do you wanted to do maybe with
the trade yeah with the trade I wanted
the bishop her you know that's that
thing that grandmaster's love the
imbalance of the two Bishops yeah Bishop
B3 and then
I'm a bit worried about because I'm
worried some what what might happen here
is black will play Rook E8 or queen E7
black will play Bishop B6 and we once
again will uh have to sort of worry
about the like all the end games if we
leave the pawn on
A2 and the bishops come off and more
pieces come off we will have actual
unpleasant 10 games totally and this
particular Pawn structure but what I was
hoping for was just to
initiate something we play you play very
clever move so I hadn't thought of H3 I
was thinking of D4 immediately D4 but
but then yeah this is this is where it
becomes our Center gets pressured and
this is once again where I want to bring
attention to this bishop on C1 in
particular because oops sorry that
wasn't what I meant in particular
because H6 has already been played right
no Bishop we will we will struggle to
find anything anything to do with that
bishop and the Knight on F3 is also
reasonably well controlled by these two
so we're not pushing for A4 we're not
really pushing in the Center this is a
very very solid setup black wants at
some point maybe bishop B6 and ask you
do you want to play D5 do you want to
let me trade
Bishops I think maybe we do have Knight
takes B6 a takes B6 we'll I just wanted
to to to to continue with this I
think it's only just the sort of the
bitter experience that taught me this is
not great because when people began
playing the structures against me my
initial thought was I will get something
like this and I will be better because I
have the Bishops I have the center why
would I not be better yeah right and
then I got this against strong players a
couple of times and I
realized you know on paper all of this
looks fantastic but you still have to
make moves and moves are actually harder
to come by good moves at least the moves
I like are harder to come by in the
structures than than I originally
thought and this is why I'm being uh
somewhat skeptical now but my first
reaction was exactly like yours I get
this black seems like black is just
trying to contain whatever it is I'm
doing no no real counterplay to to speak
of why shouldn't I be ahead but yeah my
experience at least
wasn't uh as as sunny as as all that and
let's check out the lifetime score
between these two players in classical
chess how do the neighbors match up with
one another JY let's check out the
neighborhood rivalry and it is five wins
to the
three and that means leavon
aronian I'm just wonder 15 draws though
yeah I'm just wondering where leavon got
the five wins he didn't get him in the
singfield cup must have been one of
those World Cup uh well not one but uh
different events uh that uh they have
played that he got the five wins uh by
the way intriguing decision uh
challenges that you were saying that
leavon has to make hay in this position
he didn't go for the Central Pawn Duo
played a move that frankly was not on my
radar yeah the a journey right C4 Knight
F1 put it on E3 G3 or to play F4 yeah
the starting point I'm guessing is
Knight E7 the bishop probably gets Dro
back to B4 exactly I like including the
five for black here just just to gain
some space control some more Square this
Knight always ends up being on G6 very
very useful KN we continue with the
original plan even even the immediate
Bishop B6 is playable but also yeah I
wonder let me let me play in a slightly
more con restrained fashion KN where do
you want to G3 E3 well it seems to me
that white is the one playing in a
really restrained fashion I I I'm
guessing he wants Bishop E3 and queen D2
and F4 at some but you you can't get an
F4 with black placing the Knight on
that's what I mean Bishop E3 Queen D2 I
have a I I need a lot of moves with
white and probably including and if you
step back with the bishop because you
know what I I like Bishop preserv yeah
of often they play D5 I would like
ideally to play both C5 and D5 but I'm
worried white will play D4 here with the
Knight already on G3 I like this a lot
more because I think we have a lot more
central control we also have that idea
that yasa mentioned in a hall whole
other structure but I think that game of
kasparov's introduced the idea of
further supporting the E4 Pawn with E3
with F3 so something like Bishop E3
followed by F3 followed by Queen G2
could become quite unpleasant here even
here black often ends up equalizing but
just like demolishing the entire center
with with with D5 but you can also just
start yourself you can you can play D6
D5 here and after Bishop B3 uh you can
play slowly but also uh something I've
learned is in this structure with the
bishop on E6 against the bishop on C2
your two Bishop Advantage isn't really
going to count for as much as it
normally should because you
you uh you just don't find a
particularly attractive job for the
bishop on C2 uh very often so 92 is an
interesting way to to keep the game keep
the game first of all going a second
it's it's an original approach I don't
think I've ever seen 92 in these
structures I will mention that there is
an option of actually forcing the bishop
trade which I don't think is bad or yeah
I think I think this is quite playable
Knight A5 pretty much forcing Bishop D7
Queen D7 and then we won just ideally
once again C5 Knight C6 D5 right uh but
if it gets chased away it gets chased
away there is another option I just
wanted to point out because immediately
I was drawn to going A4 but A4 doesn't
work because of C6 and then suddenly oh
no I've got got into trouble that right
for for a specific reason only I think
this would have been playable but
there's a there's a tactic here because
Knight takes D6 Bishop G4 works out for
black with Queen takes C6 being a threat
but the idea I really wanted to point
out was that after A4 mhm so Bishop
takes bishop and a takes that night on
A5 yeah a little embarrassing isn't it
it's not coming I did think you know it
was tempted to kind of go C4 to keep the
dream alive yeah but that doesn't seem
to work out specific yeah C after C4
even even this is quite playable but I
can also claim that I've achieved
something me of just play C5 put it back
yeah exactly but I I I sometimes it's
worth giving up a pawn to saddle your
opponent's Knight on the edge of the
board it it is yeah uh KN A5 actually
the more I look at this the more I like
it because this is exactly the kind of
material we want here white can play D4
we will probably bring the Knight back
you play Knight
F1
and although yeah this is where Knight
D2 is is a very very nice flexible move
by the because having it on G3 I will
start having to worry about my king side
here a little bit let's make some moves
elsewhere like we we get to some
position like this and suddenly Bishop
takes H6 is a very serious threat Knight
the five Queen G3 is a very serious
threat so you do have to you do have to
pay attention here by the way uh
laner uh comfortably ahead on uh the
clock as Leon's decision maneuver Knight
F3 D2 took him some time and lanir is
saying what are you doing exactly uh
with the your pieces uh Knight D2 I like
Knight A5 but again I thought Knight E7
was the simplest back over I'm I'm just
I'm just giggling at this uh because uh
uh 136 oh
136 yeah 136 here for for Yan in a
position which I would not described as
you know being arrived at by force you
know so either he just absolutely knows
everything today which is once again we
keep on coming back to the fact this is
somebody who prepared for two World
Championship matches so he's got a lot
in his quiver he is very very well
prepared Anish mentioned him as somebody
who is in a three-way race for the best
prepared player in the world uh during
one of the interviews or or he is in one
of his moods yeah where he just feels
okay this has been a very met tournament
I was not really given a chance to play
in very many of my games uh because
indeed many of his black games in this
tournament were just him showing Forest
draws to people yes and people seemingly
being completely okay with that no than
for showing me your files no blame
attaches whatsoever to Yan he's playing
his repertoire he knows it really well
repertoire is solid but he also would
very much like to to to actually fight
over the board he likes chess I know
this for a fact but many of his BL games
were kind of non-events and his white
games he missed some very promising
opportunities he missed a completely
winning position against ler which would
have actually changed that tournament
dramatic dramatically L is now in a TI
for first but uh he was dead lost
against Yan in that early game he had
decent chances against alza he had
chances against Fabi at one point so his
white tournament was very interesting
his black tournament not so much exactly
for those of you joining us late we H
the players had reached this position uh
Yan uh with his 19th move played Queen
B3 and Not only was uh Yan playing
quickly but these moves were not obvious
and uh while Anish was was uh carefully
considering each and every move Yan was
gaining time on the clock he started the
he started the tournament with 90
minutes he now has 96 minutes on his
clock and this position after the move
Rook D2 I would have stopped and you
know like really started considering how
do I evict this Rook from at the second
rank should I be playing moves like Rook
B1 and Rook E2 I already got schooled
that Rook D3 for tactical reasons
doesn't work very well and you know
completely unimpeded Yan has been
playing very very quickly A2 A4 engine
approved uh it's some move it's uh Peter
you can do other things as well but
after Rook G2 it seems like white
doesn't really have very many productive
things to do with our pieces but we do
absolutely both for future end games and
also just a very simple threat yeah if
if black continues doing nothing and we
can lend this on A6 while The Rook is
still back on B8 that's our it's a very
it's a very good uh thing to aim for
right uh the issue here for white is
that if Black Goes Queen d8 which
appears to be at least one of the
suggested replies with black
we are liquidating into an end game
which is uh still a pawn down end game
for black right but the full control
over the one open file plus these
somewhat inactive pieces this really
awkward Rook on G3 right it feels like
this is probably enough for black if we
go Rook B1 here black can play Knight
F4 with the Rook on B5 on B1 the the
whole A4 A5 A6 pushes kind of no longer
instead of going Rook B1 go B4 yeah you
can play both B4 and B3 after B4 you you
kind of have to contend with for
instance Rook 2 D4 which wians the pawn
on C4 immediately you do get to play B5
trade some pawns you're not Forest but
you're probably also not better here I
don't think trying to get a passport I
know a logical continuation here is
something like B3 if you play Knight F4
white will play A5 and against the dream
scenario for white here is to get to
play Knight A4 and Knight C5 and then
you might actually be better but after
B3 the issue for white is Rook B2 and
you're kind of obliged to go Knight D1
because you're really not giving up on
B3 right so Knight D1 rook bd2 and once
again you're probably going back yeah so
this is kind of hanging over us as a as
a great big threat to our to our game
here and Che two match up with all right
let's do it let's do it what are you
predicting and there we can see is as
even as you get with both players having
three wins a piece five draws so nothing
separates these two in terms of their
history but they're still a lot to play
for in terms of the tournament
absolutely
uh I find it Well the one player I
really experienced most against was V
Swan nand but I find it really
off-putting personally professionally
when I'm playing a guy like Yan who
answers everything
instantly and I'm thinking 5 minutes 10
minutes my clock is seeping and I just
feel like I mean I'm under the gun I
mean don't you have that doesn't that
make you feel awkward beater when your
opponent you with every because you come
up with a move that you you've used some
brain power for and they just go no it
was in my book you're I analyze it and
you're thinking oh why right sometimes
it just it just feels like they know
everything and you're in the dark it's
not a very comfortable feeling but uh
people generally by this point have had
some experience with this yeah vishy
would be a very good candidate and Yan
also and with with Yan you can also get
it in two different ways as I mentioned
like sometimes he's just extremely well
booked up and sometimes he just comes to
the board and says I will trust my
instincts today and I will just play
extremely quickly and he is one of the
very very few people in the world I
think who is capable of playing very
well in this mode because generally I
think it leads to self-combustion but
not with not every single time with Yan
at least wasn't this a like a small
Achilles Hill for Yan the speed of what
which he played know making making
superficial decisions we saw it in his
game against Lena Dominguez played some
very quick moves yet on the other hand
he is a streaky player who when he's
feeling confident he can go 60 I
remember him in Baku on the Olympiad
playing for the Russian Squad and just
point after point after point and he was
playing
incredibly rapidly and just winning his
games very quickly sometimes it costs
him against the absolute absolute top
but when he's in
form there is like the confusing is he
playing so fast because everything is
prepared or is he just in some kind of a
mode of let's go let's go let's play you
you also have to try try and gauge that
somehow yeah you don't know well what
what is it you're going to find uh
against the move Queen d8 uh you were
very quick to uh point out this ending I
just wanted to visit it again because I
I didn't know uh how you assessed at the
end of the story R 4 I think black has
enough I think we will find it extremely
difficult to smoke out smoke out the The
Rook on D2 and while it's still on D2 is
just very difficult for me to believe we
can be better so if I go even something
like Rook C2 here I think is quite
interesting trying to Le the other the
other one to and then you will really
stop enjoying your your position
the others if the other one LS it's not
going to be much fun The Rook can come
to F3 to defend F2 I was just looking at
um I somebody has to get rid of these
Rooks I just didn't know well at the
very least I can take and take on and
you're just I suspect Rook C1 is just
winning by the way in this right now I
think Rook C1 ends the game right yes oh
it does that's a nice one and then
things will happen to yeah this is the
92 check very
oops that is it and uh well uh it's been
a slow Championship round or maybe a
fast depending on how you would evaluate
the very at the minute and uh let's
check out the results so far because we
did see a draw between Maxim Vash lra
and Ali res it was an all French
encounter that was settled peacefully
but in the other games very much
everything still to play for and
everything still on the line absolutely
as our two tournament co-leaders are uh
at work uh Fabby and lanir in very tense
games we're going to get ready for our
break but as we do uh we're going to
check in uh with our friends at Q
Boutique stl.com to see what they have
on sale and it's going to be a 2023 SFL
cup jacket uh as the cup comes to a
close we are excited to share with you
our sink fill cup jackets and socks
forgot about the socks while supplies
last this year's amazingly comfortable
SFI cup jacket can keep you warm for
years to come it features an
embroideried 2023 SFI Cup logo on the
left breast the St Louis chess club logo
on the back of the neck and the 2023
Grand chest tour logo on the right
sleeve the jacket is available in both
men's and women's Styles we are also
proud to present the 2023 SFI socks stay
on the
move with these full calf length socks
they are comfortable and sporty very
important when you're at a chess game to
be sporty and are great for the gym or
the chessboard or anywhere in between
get both the jacket and a pair of socks
so you can represent the sink Cup on top
here it comes to the
bottom nicely done yeah but definitely
go and check out
Boutique website or in person and we're
going to go on our first break of the
day but we have a nice video lined up in
store for you which is when Anastasia
earlier on spoke to Wesley so we're
going to see you in a few minutes but
don't go anywhere because coming up soon
is going to be an interview with uh Gary
Kasparov who joins us very nice live
okay looking forward to see you on the
other side of the
break
[Music]
Wesley welcome to St Louis welcome for
granch tour I was wondering what is now
uh your position in the granch tour for
the moment uh after the previous events
and what are you looking forward to
achieve let's say during those two
events yeah I think I'm in a pretty
reasonable spot to finish in the top
three I'd say so it's also very
important for me to try to qualify for
next year's grandchester so actually now
that you mention it there's quite a lot
of steak for for me for we speak about
it for sure yes because it's uh it's
very difficult to get into the
grandchester the spots are very limited
and uh uh there are you know many
players who are joining also you got uh
Richard report and Yan Kristoff Duda who
represent Europe uh represent Poland and
Romania respectively so you really have
to fight your way for it so I'm I guess
now I mention it reminds me that I
really have to do well
to I think you have to do well because
of so many reasons also this those two
events are part of the fedus circuit and
you are still fighting for the sport in
the CID this tournament right now you're
as far as I remember you are on the
third position after Fabi I mean who has
already got the spot an than you so
let's say what do you think about it you
have so many goals to achieve and do you
feel extra pressure because of that or
not no I don't really feel extra
pressure because I mean if you qualify
for the candidates is well and good and
I probably should at some point you know
really put uh put a fire to my feet to
Target the candidates but at the same
time my mentality is that even if you
qualify for candidates uh with eight
strong players you still have to win it
to really get to the top but uh so it's
not like your priority you mean in life
to get to the
candidates uh well it's a good thing to
very good thing to qualify it's like
money know it's good to have but not
exactly my priority uh I also tend to do
badly when put too much pressure you
know when person people tell me I have
to win this and then I have to qualify
and then win that tournament and then
beat the guy and then be a world
champion it should doesn't do well with
me but at the same time I have to be
less laidback I think I have to just
start playing better and spend more time
my chest I mean I put some hours of work
my chest regularly and then just try to
be happy and play my best uh in a way I
can am like Vish Anan he said he plays
his best chest when he's happy and and
relaxed uh but I me know I would love to
qualify for next year's Grand gester and
uh it'll be be nice if I qualify for the
candidates so those are my two goals
right now obviously qualifying for next
year's crunches is the most important
goal and then if there's a slight chance
to qualify for the candidates then it's
it's good but uh um basically I set up
three goals for this year and I sailed
them all so which
one no in T I had an interview and they
asked me what my goals were for this
year and uh you know BAS basically fail
them all one is to qualify for
grandchester one is to try to get to top
five or top three can't remember exactly
in classical and one is to win a big
online chess tournament well the year's
not over yet but the year is not over so
maybe you will actually you do even
better than what you wished
before yeah the year is not over yet but
uh uh I I think as Magnus used to say
you have to enjoy the process and not
focus on the result too much uh but you
know it's it's it's good you know I mean
I I think I'm just happy to have a
career to you know to play chess I I I
love playing Chef I enjoy playing the
game and know happy to be alive oh
that's such a great approach I mean many
players should listen to this interview
and have it in mind you know that
sometimes if you are too focused on your
goals it can actually um you can forget
about the process and enjoyment right
yeah for sure I've heard many players
who say that they B their best results
when they have no goals or they have no
expectations but again I don't think it
works with everyone it very much depends
on your personality for example I don't
think it would work on Gary kasaro for
example to have no goals but it differs
per person all the best of luck for your
wrestling the tournament thank you yeah
I really need
that
hello I'm women's grandmas viim to
janova I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St lewises club.org to claim
your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St Lucia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's uh it's there it is
there it will be there I think it sense
a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Al flat by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 100 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St lisess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas R
TOA I will take you behind the scenes of
the grest St follow us on social media
and don't miss out on players interviews
and more content from the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today
we are back at it's Championship round
of the sink fi cup everything will be
decided today Absolut well we started
with a lot of action on the board but we
did have one result it was a peaceful
draw between the all French encounter
between Maxim Vash gra and Ali Resa fuia
but on the other boards still very much
in play
exciting games going on yeah especially
in our fight between our co-leaders uh
fabby's game with Richie very intriguing
middle game as is the game between
leavon and lenir the also confounding
game for me uh Peter has been that game
between nepo and an nishe when we were
leaving I was thinking to myself C5 is
just a bad move on so many levels and I
was shocked that during our Bri bre yeah
I was I was absolutely I gave the whole
impassioned speech about how I I'm I'm
very certain this is how the game will
end because it looked logical and uh
accurate it seemed like de deviating
from that introduces a lot of risk in
the position and the way you would maybe
avoid it was to play Maybe Queen B4 but
C5 apart from the fact that you can
actually uh do what uh Anish has done
and and go for this position and now I
think Rook A8 is a very attractive move
in producing the idea of Rook takes B6
and then Rook takes A1 I don't see how
white should be better here which is
another reason not not
reallyis but a much bigger issue here
for white is we've interrupted the
connection between the queen on B6 and
the pawn on F2 and black could very very
justifiably just switch back to
attacking the king side uh in particular
H5 H4 here using the moment to do it
when white cannot get the Queens off the
board because the pawn and B2 will fall
next move the Rook needs to to go to uh
a square I guess E3 is slightly more
comfortable than F3 but regardless of
what you choose I'm going to play Queen
G5 I'm going to play Knight F4 I'm going
to play Rook bd8 and I'm going to say I
no longer care about the queen side I
will make progress here this and if I do
very dangerous if I do you will not
enjoy it no no who can resist free food
though no well but this was a huge
attack I would never have walked in H4
is very strong but even more simply even
a full Tempo down here you can start
with Queen F6 and then follow it up
let's say Rook F3 Knight F4 we already
threatening Knight takes H3 which is
going to be quite difficult to Parry and
I'm obviously a bit influenced by the
fact that the engine instantly starts
liking black here great deal but I think
I would have been very interested in the
game and this is where we also have to
come back to what we're discussing
throughout the entirety of our coverage
of this game Yan has only just now
dipped below 90 minutes mhm uh when he
played C5 I think that was the first
move where he sort of thought for a bit
but he was still above 90 minutes Anish
is on 38 andish is an hour behind by by
move 24 wow which I think influences you
in a way that you feel you can't
completely rule out your opponent
actually still being very much in book
this being Yan pomi and his his two
World Championship matches in some
positions it's more likely than others
but you can't completely Ru it out even
in this seemingly completely random
position and also you're sort of
entering the the situation where you
might be in significant time
trouble uh all of which I think pushed
Anish into a more safety orientated way
uh decision uh I think if he had more
time and Yan was also thinking Anish
would be very very interested about the
idea of giving mate on the king side but
as it happened he took on B6 he took on
B5 A5 Rook eight also was played and now
A6 was played and this seems like thise
equalizes for white the interesting part
for me is why Rook takes B6 isn't
winning yes but we go Knight A4 and
after let's say Rook B4 Knight C5 is
very very strong attacking attacking
everything we're threatening this is
where black would like to have his Pawn
back on H7 for the first time of the
game Jo The Rook on G3 is well placed
you're actually threatening
G6 yeah and and this gives white time to
take on B7 and once again obviously you
would like to win a piece but not when
it promotes not when it promotes a pawn
for white and you don't like even let's
say in this position even if you do win
the pawn on e4 you pretty much never go
for this with black on a because yeah it
feels like you're playing for a loss
maybe you don't lose but you're
definitely trying to lose here giving
white this this passer making so in in
the position after Rook takes B6 and
Knight A4 probably the correct course of
action is to go for this position white
does unpin himself in time with Rook G3
you play something like Rook A5 because
once again allowing allowing Knight C5
is unnecessary but this feels dangerous
for black here exchange I think it's
okay I think I think the this the pawn
structure is solid enough and White's
pieces are kind of awkward enough that
this shouldn't be so bad I guess the
Knight gets transferred over to D3 to
control the Knight on G6 I would agree
with you that if anybody is going to
play this for it's probably white mhm
but I also think it's it's it's fine
it's fine yeah and the other move we
need to discuss after A6 is B takes A6
but here once again white goes Knight A4
let's say Rook B4 we go Knight
C5 and the combined the combined threats
on both the king side and the queen
side strictly speaking the only move
here is Bishop C8 because allowing B7
will lose you the game and you cannot do
this this loses you a lot of material so
you have to play Bishop C8 and in this
position white for instance can switch
to playing against the black king
weirdly Rook D1 creates an Unstoppable
idea of Rook d8 Check Yes white is two
pawns down but white suddenly starts
generating a lot of play Massive threat
against the white king side and also
this this whole setup is going to be
very very tied down white is definitely
not not worse here the question is
whether white is better is very open I
don't think uh this is anything against
best play but best play is not always a
achievable so this has definitely
sharpened up right but really not in the
way that I expected I thought yeah I
mean C5 looked borderline unplayable to
me but as things standed it may have
been a pretty decent
Bluff impressive we'll keep an eye on
that one Peter uh tell us once again uh
remind our viewers about the grand chest
tour the standings are winner of the
grand chest tour and there are three
play possible uh players who would get
an invite well it's not a contest for
the top because Fabiana Cara has won
that one out right two rounds to spare
everything still to play for when it
comes to second and third placing
remember the top three finishers do get
an automatic invitation into 2024's
Grand chest tour and uh weso has
definitely guaranteed his spot in top
three of the grand chest tour remember
Wesley so has a buy today so his
tournament has been completed but fuja
is officially out of the top three after
his minus two performance and his draw
against Maxine Vash theth what a year
difference makes Ali Rea our defending
2022 tour Champion uh won everything a
year ago he's out of the top three
continue please the max te V gr spot in
the top three is guaranteed he drew if
yes he drew if he draws yeah but in any
case except if both npom Nashi and
leavon aronian win Andi we saw has a
very interesting very promising position
against Anish
giri and uh for leavon he is facing off
with the white pieces against lenia
Dominguez so maybe that can happen but
nepo can claim the third spot from Maxim
bashel graph if he and both leevon win
their games mvl is not going to lose
because as you said already mvl has
drawn his game so he has to win and
leavon also has to win for nepo to get
the guaranteed top three and here's
where we stand exactly at the moment uh
with the the GCT yes uh so the these are
the scores just after the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and Fabiano Carana 33 points
he started with 11o Head Start Over Max
bash de graph and uh his performance
here has been sufficient for him to win
the title of grandchester champion and
Maxim B gra there on 22 points Maxim's
finished with a 50% score right and
everything will hinge on this battle
between yanmi and Maxi and wesle so did
finish on plus one it's undetermined
what place he will finish on until these
games are over speaking of these games
uh Peter do the honors we're looking at
the game between leavon white lanir
Dominguez black and I must say I really
like the way lanir has played this game
so far I think I think it's a very
logical uh logical play by ler so far
after after the move 9 D2 ler included
Rook E8 a move which I felt could have
been saved on but as things stand right
now it's almost always in the structures
is going to be useful right they won
continued logically with Knight F1
Knight E7 now uh Bishop C4 I would have
thought was the idea but one thing you
have to keep in mind is there is always
this kind of a clever little move Bishop
A4 uh which often will force you to
trade the Bishops anyway because if if
if Queen goes somewhere now your Bishop
no longer has any squares because you
have this P along the a file and 2 B3
and the bishop drops back you're also
creating a situation for yourself which
is not very pleasant so you end up
playing Bishop B3 anyway but then you
should have taken on D7 you're not
really improving your position by doing
this yeah so Bishop B7 Queen D7 ight G3
uh D4 first ight G6 ight G3 I very much
like the move B6 B5 here uh because it
establishes a kind of
a uh wave breaker preventing V from
perhaps achieving the the structure with
D5 followed by C4 and B3 okay now if
white ever feels like you want to play
D4 D5 which is something we will discuss
in a moment you will always get
immediately uh hit by C7 C6 Leon played
F2 F3 this which is something that we've
discussed supporting the pawn on e4 uh
because if you play Bishop E3 here you
do have to worry about D6 D5 in some
positions although not in this one you
have to worry about e takes D4 because
the pawn E4 is hanging here you're quite
happy to recapture with the bishop so
that would have been a m of right but F3
is logical F3 is something that I think
Leon also quite likes in the structures
I recently had a game against him where
he was also going specifically for this
uh setup against the knights on F6 and
G6 but his issue is after Rook a d8
you've sort of run out of useful moves
mhm what you do want to play is Bishop
B3 right it looks Lal yeah but it allows
D6 D5 which is what black is very much
aiming for and now my original uh
confusion about this was I thought what
white always wants to do in response is
provoke a piece to enter the E5 square
and then go F4 and E5 let's do it but
here very specifically you can take on
B2 what and then return to C4 once the
Knight gets attacked like if if you play
something like Queen F3 I will of course
move move my knight away from F6 but if
you try to attack the Knight on B2 and
then win one of them there is no Square
on the board for white that also
protects the bishop P E3 so you play
something like Queen C2 I go Knight C4
and yes you can play something like
Bishop G4 and claim you have positional
compensation for the pawn but it's
unclear how good these these positions
are because this is a marvelous
marvelous piece yeah in that position
Peter could I try Queen B3 and can I get
my can I disrupt your king side Take
That Knight take that PA let's go with
the oh maybe Rook I don't know okay take
that pawn I I was trying to just uh uh
prove your tuers really aren't you know
very close
to come on
Joey climb a board you know the G up the
G up isn't really happening I lost the
cheerleader over she wasn't happy with
my attack I I did also consider that
there is a possibility to get into a
position where it's um you get the two
minor pieces so for instance you can go
Queen C1 yeah uh this was something I
was wondering about as well and now
let's say queen I don't know G2
somewhere and then you tra the but I
felt that this was there's also rookie
three and Knight C2 or the Knight C2
immediately which isn't which isn't that
great so this appears to work out and
the proper response is to just say okay
I sort of semi blunder the pawn but I
will now if the Knight goes away I will
play I don't know Knight A5 or F five A6
and I will play for a lot of play on the
king side but very often the black will
just black will just return this Pawn
and then prepare and push B6 C5 get rid
of this bishop Pawn
D4 end games are dangerous for white
here so it very much becomes you know a
race for white to create something on
the king side perhaps or maybe somehow
get rid of the Pawn on A2 if let's say
you at some point manage to play four
and trade it off your end gamees become
better because otherwise it will be a
Target but I'm I think I'm pretty much
always choosing black in a position like
this uh this would be a very comfortable
situation and Leon I think after
considering everything that we just
discussed he goes for a somewhat uh
disheartening I think decision of D Tak
C5 because this is clearly not the dream
no this is not what he was playing for
but he realized that stopping D6 D5 is
absolutely massive priority for him
right uh you can take with the Knight
you can also take with the pawn after
which the bishop will come to E3 and
will get a very dry position obviously
the removal of the G pawns from the
board makes it easier for black to
control this but you still maybe prefer
the B a little bit yeah as well as the
trade of the queen yeah we can also we
can also get all of these off the board
and play something like Knight of8 kn6
but maybe wife will be a little bit
better the night on Five will be
annoying too don't really have to give
up the defile do I Peter can I
absolutely not yeah you can go go fight
immediately yeah that's much better
actually I don't know why I took on the
one and yeah that does feel a bit yeah
something something like this something
like this is not very exciting you
probably at some point play H5 and six
get rid of this night but for leavon uh
pardon me for lanir this is a kind of
dream come true because again he's
coming into the round at plus two he's
co-leader he has black against very very
strong opponent and he's equalized I
think so yeah I think I think he'll be
very satisfied once D5 lands and he
realizes that you know the big strategic
danger of white preserving the Pawns in
the center and then eventually starting
something because after Bishop B3 if you
don't play D5 straight away white gets
to play something like Queen
G2 C6 we play Queen G2 once again D5 is
working but if it wasn't if like if we
make one more W que C7 I'm already
looking at like Knight five Bishop H6 or
even the immediate Bishop H6 yeah it's
going and once this happens you will you
will really struggle to to contain the
activity both both in the center and uh
against H6 Pawn so yeah D5 is a very
welcome development for uh laner and in
our other game between yes exactly how
is aabi who as we know is our grand
chest T winner
2023 will he put a book end to this game
will we see
playoffs looks possible right this
moment what's going on Peter tell yeah
Bishop A6 was eventually played it was
played slower than I expected if I'm
entirely honest uh Richie I think uh I
think he is in a kind of a mood today
that he thought maybe there is some kind
of a dream world possible in which I
play Bishop B7 for by Knight bd7 and
then I push C5 and the bishop on B7
survives which would have been even more
exciting for for black but this feels
like you probably aren't going to get as
much Freedom here as you would like C5
you need to contend with D5 you need to
contend with Bishop D6 it probably isn't
going to happen for you exactly so he
does Play Bishop A6 Fabi goes with uh
takes takes on Queen A4 trying to use
the fact that this Knight is somewhat
misplaced Queen B6 is a logical response
and now Bishop F4 was played by Fabiano
and even the immediate 6 C5 might be
playable you can also go uh maybe not
Knight B before because of Bishop D6 you
can go Knight C7 Knight
G5 this feels honestly kind of okay for
black I mean E7 E6 G7 G6 worked out bril
worked out it worked out fine yeah
worked out fine but uh isn't Fabby just
going to plunk the bishop on E5 and yeah
let's yeah like something something like
this I will focus my energy on doubling
don't forget B2 is potentially weak at
some point I will start considering when
yeah there is an issue potential issue
but okay you know I mean you can clamp
down on one weakness the C6 uh Pawn but
you know one thing you do have to
consider and the reason for instance I'm
not suggesting the immediate 95 is I
think in particular we left with this
Knight right these types of structures
could potentially be very very dangerous
yeah put the Knight anywhere else F5 H5
H6 kind of happy so I think first
priority for black here is to normalize
this piece put it on a good square right
and then strategically as as Yanka was
saying these two uh
generally they're considered to sort of
neut yeah cancel each other out because
the weakness on six is uh compensated
for by the weakness on D4 it all feels
pretty level uh it's still an
interesting position but doesn't feel
like I think the excitement is a nepo
and a niche I mean it might be it might
just Peter out but what do we have on
the it was an exchange sacrif they've
progressed all the way to here we had
this position on the board I was showing
I was showing this line so Rook takes B6
happened Knight C3 A4 happened Rook B6
takes A6 happened this didn't happen of
course uh the exchange was picked up
rook G3 looks
logical Knight C5 not allowing Knight C5
looks logical putting Knight on a square
where it doesn't allow Knight F4 also
looks logical and now you can play C5
although you have to worry about the
Rooks coming off the board you can play
B6 actually I think the engine prefers
B6 specifically so that this doesn't
happen because it we've discussed this
earlier during one of the earlier shows
mhm with this material imbalance what
black really really wants to avoid is
the trade of Rooks MH because with with
the Rook still on the board you have
some way of controlling the white
activity whereas with one Rook against
no Rooks I think Yan immediately feels a
lot better about life and B6 has by now
been played by by Anish is the black
king in any form of danger it's
difficult to imagine so because actually
now we're kind of grateful for H5 it
gives us an additional an additional way
out yeah yeah no I was I was wondering
whether the Knight could suddenly find
itself on F3
and
long Rook B8 could be played first and
then you try let's try pushing yeah so
you drop it back I guess fly enough I'm
not really happy about the Knight
anymore the desirable Rook A6 maybe my
king could come under uh dur rest also I
I actually no it has the C5
score trapped right so we start with
this and we we force it back and then we
go Rook B1 this could become dangerous
for yeah yeah absolutely I think Rook A6
is just a mistake you have to play
something else maybe Knight E1 Knight F3
so Knight Knight
E1 but even something like maybe Knight
F4 I'm worried I will blend the G like
my my intention was to do something like
this but then but then you do have this
idea Rook A7 rook bb7 and this is
vulnerable so let's think about things
for a second maybe the setup to aim for
is just to play I don't know H5 H4 not a
three King h six and say because I
control the h8 square with the Knight be
yeah it's going to although now I've
allowed Rook A6 yes now and maybe I
maybe I make a draw I mean I'm pretty
sure I do make a draw by attacking the
F2 Pawn right and then giving more of
these
checks but V has at least
stabilized I think we're getting a
little bit carried away trying to guess
exactly what will happen um but I think
you uh pointed out the Contours of the
position and what the two players are
aiming for
what was your strength would you say
were you a chess master when you
understood that the imbalance when you
had the extra exchange you wanted to
take off a rook how good were you when
that knowledge that awareness came to
you I was still a class player and I
didn't know that I should be trying to
trade a yeah that that kind of occurred
when I started studying with other
International Masters and we started
sharing ideas and one person was talking
about tan Pion and the way that he
sacrificed The Exchange so I started
studying his games and so I think I was
around about 24 when that happen at 2400
level okay so you're already very very
strong yeah yeah but even even now I
still have a very big reluctance
to go leave myself and exchange down but
I managed to reconcile it a little bit
when uh I was training with a a
Grandmaster and he said me you know
you're you're hung up on the classical
scoring system of like a piece being
three a rook being five a queen being
nine it's there one way to overcome that
kind of thinking is that uh you you have
like a fluctuating scale so a rook is
worth five but only when it's on an open
Line mhm and uh a night it can be worth
three even up to five if it's like
anchored right in the middle of the
board right and then the bishop goes the
same if it's on a long diagonal with
some purpose you know a very strong
piece May a lot more than a rook so that
helped me just get over and shake those
kind of shackles of the traditional the
my Bishop on G2 which is absolutely
terrible because it's behind a Pawn on
e4 and there's a Pawn on H3 shouldn't be
worth three anymore because it's not
doing anything so why could why give the
bishop a whole credit of being worth
three points uh by the way I just see
now that some moves were made in the
game of leavon and some of them R
everywhere and some of them are quite
surprising let's stick with this one for
a second because y Yeah by this point
yeah let's restate once again it's one
Little
Guy Peter this is this is
absolutely absolutely one of the days
where Yan just says to himself I do not
care for that thinking business I am not
going to be doing any of it I will just
trust I will just trust my natural gift
because yeah there is no way you get
here with like 10 minutes spent no
matter no matter how many of these are
in his in his files some you need to
start thinking and the point is Bishop
H3 by the way has been played he wants
to play F4 and kind of play against this
uh Knight on G6 cut it off also improve
the king because we were often even
demonstrated some lines where the King
was a bit awkward and now it has some
breathing space it's still a very
striking decisions to decision to make
in like 3 minutes flat or something
three ponds for the exchange Peter I
would have I would feel like as if I was
in Anisha shoes I'd be getting
optimistic do you know something I had a
situation like this um I I don't think
he was a grandmas at the time but I was
black against an international Master
very strong player and I did one of
those type of moves G yeah G3 go for it
take the pawn take the pawn and you and
it was a rook actually could have take
could take my Pawn Yeah with chck as
well and there was like some
triangulation with the King and I
remember his look at me he looked at me
like why are you playing like this right
like it actually one of the best games
of my life because I'd worked out that
he could he could take the porn and yeah
but that my king would do some funny
triangulation and then I would be the
one using the open G line and and like
now I look at like what Yan's done and
I'm liking it yeah I understand like it
was a third porn to the good but I think
it's very inconvenient to play against
you know because you do have ideas of F5
the Knight was going to find itself at
home on F4 and Knight E5 as well as
Peter's indicating
let's say 65 happens yeah so the the the
moral of the story is Beware Of Joy
offering pawns uh she doesn't give them
lightly but uh point out what's going on
cuz I'm confused Bishop G4 Bishop G4
talking F2 allow M B2 is uh not great
not the idea yeah this is very very
nonobvious to me and also pretty decent
it's maybe not the best thing he could
have done but it really doesn't change
the evaluation and when you know we get
here right and we think about this
position after B6 and for me to realize
that a move that just gives up a full
pawn and also gives black the way it's
played I mean gf4 hasn't been played
which I think indicates that Yan isn't
at the board
so what he's done in the two and a half
moves between this position and this
position he sacrificed the pawn in then
game and gave black an outside passer on
the H file right and the evaluation
stays equal wow this means this is a
pretty decent idea that many people
would absolutely fail to consider and I
count myself very much among that number
three so uh he's playing well it's a
very very unusual idea it would take me
a long time to figure out that
my piece activity the fact that I'm now
very much playing against like I I do
not want to give any squares to The Rook
on B5 as you can see currently on it it
just does nothing whatsoever it has has
nowhere to go
and his followup is often I think white
goes Rook A7 here there is also this
idea for instance against King H7 ex
there's this idea of playing Rook C1
specifically provoking C5 and then
playing F5 and asking the Knight to go
to some really uncomfortable squares
apparently if you go Knight 97 now that
move I was indicating 95 this position
suddenly white is better maybe not
enough to win the game but white is
suddenly having pushing having by far
the the best chances so the engine
suggests you have to go to H4 and now
you have to be really certain you don't
lose any material because like give me
one move here to play King G3 and I will
start collecting stuff but somehow after
R2 check King G3 and G5 it all sort of
works out for black okay uh so yan yan
managed to sharpen up this position
brilliantly and unfortunately for him
they've been played so quickly that they
already reached move 35 so his one hour
advantage on the clock isn't going to be
as telling because
Anish has only five moves to make but
right this is actually like a very very
good demonstration of just how good a
chess Yan is naturally MH because I'm
pretty sure this is no longer book and
hasn't been booked for a while and he is
still finding these things which are
quite difficult to find the
short periods of time exactly so once
again so if we play Bishop G4 King F2 H4
I you do your work run run run run run
run for for instance we can do this I
think right because it seems like I
blundered another one but I actually
haven't how many pawns do I get for The
Rook you might you might not lose even
this one but I think they get I think
they get I've had this one before Five
Pawns for The Rook they're not enough
they're not enough is that not enough I
mean they need to be I think they need
to be further Advanced I think they get
picked off one by I remember Arena crush
and Alice Lee playing rook and four
pawns uh four pawns versus a rook yeah
and it ended in a draw that this was
five uh but you're right uh I think I
think they start dropping off I mean
Bishop takes F5 as a mistake you play
something like F6 King F4 Bishop H5 you
will you will Sur that I didn't play but
now we now we start asking you all of
these questions
now I'm not so happy that I played H4
sorry I didn't play King H7 yet Rook H1
and you kind of have to play G5 but
you'll you'll still survive this it's
not it's not that bad but you you see
how things can go wrong us us giving up
this H Pawn and bringing the king into
the game and opening up some very
unusual files for our PES very often
leads to why developing quite a lot of
activity which wasn't really there in
the position a moment ago on offer yeah
Bishop G4 hasn't been played yet I was
slightly head of the game here the the
the thing that's really bothering me is
this Knight on G6 I don't want to go it
to go to E7 because I think after
knight7 kn5 I kind of get dominated
Knight f8 only invites Rook A8 and uh my
knight but yeah I I don't know if we
want to be retreating before we're
chased right it feels a bit Yeah iffy so
that was so Bishop G4 King F2 Knight H4
Knight F3 I think it's early I think
it's early but also I think we should
let Anish think here I'm very curious
how he will react he doesn't have uh too
much time uh 23 uh minutes but let's uh
jump back to uh Fabby for a moment
because up against Richie he has played
um Rook fd8 is
lo I think stopping the Bishop from
arriving on D6 makes perfect sense sort
of reestablishing the idea of C6 C5 I
guess in some positions I think this is
just fairly balanced it's a kind of
position which could become interesting
if uh if black somehow doesn't achieve
the the ideal setup with the Knight on
D5 but if if Richard does get there
feels like there's going to be
a a perfectly fine position and Knight
after to D5 that could potentially be an
idea you know very dependent on how
white reacts here right cuz I'm worried
about playing Knight D5 while the Knight
is still on A6 yeah I'm assuming Rook AC
one as well exactly Rook AC one night
before I'm pretty sure we start by night
before yeah you got to bring this guy
back into uh civilization because you do
in this particular case once I put the
Rook on C1 right you do have a for uh
Knight to D Knight to D3 I think because
of because of Knight before Rook A1
might not be the move because
suboptimal and what about
A3 just control that I'll go the other
way see if I was playable even even
immediately after A3 you can also go
Knight C7 because we do have the the the
two different pathway yeah then I was
wondering whether you could clamp down
immediately well you you wanted to put
the bishop on E5 in other varations Jo
and I'd also like if you give me another
go go B4 as well okay so uh you see I
always thought that the weakness the
isolated Pawn on
D4 uh always offset the weakness of the
umit the night's hanging on the oh sorry
I I have to to do it in a way with oh
well how can I do this in the right way
though yeah that's that's the problem
that's why I I want to get B4 well I
think you can go B4 now but then You'
have to change the pawn
structure that is not the pawn structure
that I wanted to change um I'm going to
do I think inviting a 75 is generally
exactly but the bottom line for me was
that these two guys were offsetting uh I
got the split pawns A7 and C6 but the
isolated Pawn on D4 was always a source
of counterplay C6 C 5 is what Peter
ascribes to um you can maneuver your
knights around maybe even to B5 too by
the way it's not just a one-way traffic
on the D5 Square A3 Knight here just to
put some moves on the board Bishop E5
Knight to B5 again I I felt quite
comfortable as black in these positions
I'm going to put another move on the
board if you don't mind Rook C1 and I'll
put another move on the board A5 so
again I'm saying I've got weaknesses is
on the queen side you've got a weakness
in the center um Even Stevens uh what
you going to do Bobby Bishop E5 played
Bobby's clock time by the way it went
down yeah he say significantly 31
minutes actually half an hour and
there's still only a move
15 I think the creative play out of the
opening that richy did in this game the
schlect schav G6 with E6 included
uh definitely threw Fabby off of his
prep as it should I mean who would have
prepared for that Bishop E5 on the board
does that invite the move C6 C5 though
uh
Peter I'm trying to sort of establish
what I think about this I think it's
playable but you don't need to hurry
with it I think Knight B4 Knight D5 is
still perfectly perfectly
serviceable there's no particular reason
to to avoid playing this there's also my
B8 D7 which I wouldn't have really
considered at all but seems to be a way
to approach this position I don't think
very many human players will even you
know start thinking in that direction
okay so if you go KN to
B4 isn't it time for white to start Rook
D1 I'm see C I'm I was thinking Rook C1
because it's night3 is annoying I think
yeah night D3 bugs
me as well I think you you start by
playing Rook a rook F D1 we go like Rook
A1 sorry Rook A8 you can go Rook A1 here
and the I drops back to D5 and we and
here I wanted to play a very odd move
but I thought it might be time to drop
the queen back to see nothing nothing OD
about it it idea Knight A4 Knight C5
yeah no this is this is a dream yeah
black
could sometimes it's maybe useful to
kick the Rook away from C1 just just
pointing out that the bishop isn't
obliged to stay on G7 for the rest of
the game but as for your plan of Knight
C4 Knight A4 Knight C5 this absolutely
needs attention I I will say that I
think you can take on C3 often in these
types of positions because uh the
improving sort of the reconnecting
recapture with the pawn allows black to
play C6 C5 immediately and I think this
is fine and if you take with the queen I
will quite happily reestablish a
different Knight on D5 and once again
this type of structures They Don't
Really worry me at all with the black
pieces I think this is just completely
completely
okay yeah I think I think Richard is
just fine honestly I don't the way the
pieces are I feel weirdly Bishop A6
followed by Queen A4 if we go back here
I think Queen A4 may not have been the
move I thought Queen E2 and just because
we like you can even maybe start with
this immediately because this is going
to be very much part of your play in the
structure in general so just just plant
it plant it there play three play I
don't know Bishop E3 or Bishop A3 make
sure that you don't have to worry about
C6 C5 make sure that you can land the
Knight on C5 the moment this one goes
anywhere and go from there it's not like
white is significantly better here but
it doesn't really feel to me that
playing Queen A4 provoking Queen B6 is
actually discombobulating black in any
way I think Queen B6 is a move you're
pretty happy about playing exactly and
for white we are occupying a square that
is needed for a different piece I
absolutely agree with you with with Yi
that this is what we should be aiming
for but we've yeah we've kind of cut cut
ourselves off at the news here a little
bit yeah not before on the board uh by
the way the the position that I have on
my screen is almost uh
perfectly exemplifies what I this was
your queen C2 uh positions that I always
thought was fine Knight D5 this idea
that I have a weakness on C you have a
weakness on D4 but they're offsetting uh
so much so I didn't think either side
had a benefit from uh these two weak
imbalances my experience is is that uh
if everything is just balanced Black by
virtue of having possession of the open
e b line has some play and also has a a
lovely Square on D5 yeah no I I I don't
doubt that both players do have their
play I mean if I'm white I'm going to
try to Triple up on the C file you know
alak's gun go Rook C4 Rook C2 Queen C1
and also if the Bishops do come off the
board sometimes you can maybe in some
ideal scenarios suddenly launch
something on the king side H4 H5 let's
say Knight E5 Knight G4 and there's
suddenly something going on but black
needs to be completely oblivious to to
their surroundings for like five moves
straight yeah for this to actually be a
factor Ju Just as Peter is saying you
know you've got ideas that suddenly uh
H6 check Knight G5 something could could
could go wrong Knight G4 I'm in the
Mickey did that to me once he went like
Knight E5 Knight G6 Knight G4 when I had
a set up uh against his isolated Queen
Pond um in the game between lanir and uh
leavon again when we left it we had just
left it around these parts with d8 have
been played there was a trade he
recaptured
I found that a little bit surprising I
expected D takes E5 you more or less
above everything else uh Knight takes E5
so leavon said okay I don't really like
encouraging Knight C4 in other words if
I played Bishop E3 Knight C4 hitting B2
and Bishop so Bishop F4 is a kind of a
temporary development move if I get
another turn I get to play Queen D4 and
I bring my Rook over and r r Knight F5
I'm also looking at Knight F5
yes my eyes are focus on One Direction
only I think it comes down to whether or
not black can play D5 in certain
position I agree with that I think the
way to actually completely equalizing
these structures pretty much only is
connected with with the idea of the 65
but whether you actually get there or
not is question right yeah Queen D2 now
I was always well class my classical
training was that uh if I have a Pawn on
e4 and you have a Pawn on D6 say from a
philidor defense position I was supposed
to be better so yes I invite you to play
Knight takes E4 Queen takes uh for from
a strictly you know material point of
view it's dead even but white was always
supposed to be for choice that was why
the move D6 takes E5 would have taken
precedent uh for me um Peter your take
on this very specific position bearing
in mind that lener has just had a 20
minute think as well I think he wants to
preserve some life in the position I
think he failed didak E5 gives him
absolutely zero winning chances okay and
it's not like he is better here but here
with the queen still on the board and a
slightly uh less symmetrical structure
wow he gets perhaps to play a slightly
more double- ed position and C7 C5 is a
very interesting option here hinting at
another explanation for why the Knight
to E5 right he is saying I want to play
C5 C4 I want to plant it on D3 okay uh
and you will have to either take on E5
now which I think is a preferable uh
situation for black because we get the
same structure but without the bishop
and the Knight right it's it's going to
be even more comfortably equal as a
chess commentator one of my great Joys
is I get to sacrifice all the pieces
without any of the consequences so I'm
seeing C5 I'm seeing
in some you're going to go C4 uh play
play ball with me for just a moment I'm
going to go Queen D2 you're going to go
Knight D3 yeah now I resign after
H6 and that's Johnny ball game that's
over so uh let me play Joy's move Knight
F5 cuz that was something that you were
aspiring
towards like
gleefully Knight at5 and uh isn't this
just a little too slow five though I
think if we want to do that we have to
start with Queen D2 yes oh Queen D we
have to be bit in which was it subtle I
wanted to land like a a pound of bricks
Queen D2 is a kind of multi-purpose move
cuz you are perhaps going Rook A1 you
know Target and also I I think uh ler is
and I was thinking about it even even
after Bishop 4 immediately because you
can actually play D5 here but uh if you
do it here you're very much inviting a
move like Queen D4 followed up by 34 45
so he's G he's gone C5 and after Queen
D2 he has the improved version of the
same much improved actually because
after Bishop B5 Rook E5 you can't even
play F4 because that allows Knight takes
C4 and US putting the queen on D2 has
actually cost us very very dear with
white uh so I I think L will be very
well aware that his King side is
actually two moves away from total
disaster right like if you allow Knight
F5 and queen G2 you will have to start
making
very very sharp you know defensive
Maneuvers to to avoid to avoid getting M
straight up M but I think he's yeah he's
played C5 and he is now fairly prepared
to play D6 D5 next move against more or
less anything M nether 5 D5 uh this is
actually just very good for black
because the center
sty disintegrates it disintegrates so
quickly that we're just not going to be
able to generate any kind of Knight F5
looks premature for
it definitely does look PR and here once
again it feels like uh mass
simplifications in the center are
prescribed something along the lines of
takes takes and Rook A1 and black will
take on e4 uh we get all of these pieces
off the board and this is very level
yeah this there is not there is not a
lot going on and instead of uh Queen D2
I just wanted to have a look at a quirky
idea that I suddenly thought about
A4 it's I just wanted to prevent
D5 it
does can take on E yeah now the engine
goes Knight G6 and I think It prepares
to take on A4 and play D6
D5 or after B B3 yeah I don't know how
log how uh uh easy that is to uh to
actually do because it it puts it back
on E5 and said you haven't actually made
much progress but but giving you yet
another move because it doesn't really
feel immediately obvious to me that the
bishop is poorer on E3 than it is on F4
so by playing in this position so I just
to 96 Follow Follow by 95 looks like
I've just given up a lot of time yeah
and then the idea with A4 was just to
get my Rook to A4 and maybe develop your
Rook develop my Rook maybe swing it
across you know get ready for action on
the I like the open a file I mean
there's reasons for playing A4 here D6
D5 is coming very very quickly though
and we've also in fed the Knight to to
land on E3 so I think the big mistake
for black would be to actually be well
not not a big mistake but this is very
obliging ba4 yeah okay uh Joy before we
go on uh our break uh just break down a
little bit the candidates qualifications
cuz I'm getting a very interesting paper
here tell us to the candidates two spots
available one to the highest rated
player in January 2024 and the other one
who uh who has the top spot in the feed
circuit well Wesley so is really sitting
pretty actually as far as the ratings
spot is concerned yes he has taken over
as a potential favorite for the
candidates qualifying spot because of
his performance and if giru wants to
accumulate some points there he must
finish with a win today to keep his
candidates qualifying spot on the feed
circuit cuz remember Whoever has the
highest spots on that circuit whoever
finishes at the top of the table they
are going to Toronto in
2024 and uh if Gary does not win
Dominguez has a high chance to qualify
by ratings okay but that is definitely
dependent on whether Dominguez plays
another tournament in activity require
exactly between December and uh the
end December it can't which is
absolutely extraordinary this idea that
uh we would have uh four potential
American Qualifiers in the candidates I
mean uh we we we joked amongst ourselves
that it would be America versus India
and uh the candidates were that to
happen uh but thanks to Ben uh Underwood
for uh bringing those uh yes
uh well jockeying for position is what I
wanted to say abolutely
just incredibly thrilling and intense
but we are going to go on our second
break of the day but don't go anywhere
because coming up after the break we do
have Gary Kasparov joining us so you
don't want to be missing that it's going
to be
[Music]
epic
uh so today's Community Day all the
persons of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision-making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I played with my
auntie my my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make the bad decisions in life I can
tell you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
in check whether it's going to put put
your anything in danger whether it's
just a move that you make everything
counts in the long run I like um how it
makes me use my critical thinking makes
me look at the whole board I think it's
teaching them to be persistent you know
we have a lot of students who it takes
them like it may take a few weeks or
even months in chess club to master a
particular strategy or skill um and what
I think that teaches kids is even if
they don't get it the first time around
or even if it's difficult the first time
around um it's worth sticking to it well
one thing's for certain without the St
Louis chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
especially those in areas that are not
core content area and because of the St
Louis chess club collaboration we have
people who come in here working with
students who want to work with them to
day with the experience of the grandmas
community outreach day I came up and I'm
like well what's a grandm and they like
oh you don't know what a grandm is and
they were able to explain that and they
recognize the importance and the
seriousness I mean it's a sport it's a
profession and so they're able to see
things outside of the sports that we
typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know help my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's Grand Master V
janua I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the saint area we also promote Chess at
the highest levels hosting all levels of
the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s Lou chess
club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the the game of chess
will always stay Float by the M fact of
its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly nearly 1500 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas
Bria I will take you behind the scenes
of the gr chest store follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
premere chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
welcome back everybody it's a
championship round the sinkfield cup and
well we have one game finishing already
it was a draw between Maxine vasra and
Ali Resa fua but in the other games
there's been some intense moments but
anything can still happen absolutely in
uh one of our Marquee matchups between
leavon aronian and lanir Dominguez uh
this last move from leavon Queen D2 uh
was a clear intention and uh Joy this
idea of Knight F5 and Bishop H takes H6
is such a telegraphed shot I mean it's
like a brick falling on your toe you
will recognize that there are issues and
lanir immediately uh undertook a very
important uh move Peter D6 D5 breaking
describing and interestingly CU I I
became curious can we take the pawn we
we we this was still playable which is I
think a very interesting Testament to
just how strong the the whole idea of
bish H6 is black challenges your Center
black also introduces more squares on
the sixth rank to play against the
attack and yet still Rook Rook E6
apparently the only way to continue
Knight E5 Knight E8 defend now after
Queen G5 check uh you have to play King
f8 he would like to play Rook G6 but
that allows this very very strong Fork
on E7 right so we have to play King f8
and now after something like let's say
queen
H5 on yeah I thought King G8 repeats but
King G8 doesn't actually repeat after R
ag1 you're in trouble things start
collapsing in the center so you you you
have to drop the Knight back and not
into it you can even you can even play a
kind of a slow move here E4 E5 trying to
keep the center closed and in in all of
the variations I'm I'm looking at right
now white isn't winning but white pretty
much every single time has enough for a
draw so I just wanted to show this as an
illustration of just how strong with
even with you know few pieces on the
board and the attackers for you know the
vast majority of time we're talking here
white only has two attackers and black
seemingly has pretty much every single
piece ready to defend the King right and
there's still enough compensation so
that was that was definitely a choice
but Leon went for with the more uh
restrained approach which is something
we showed before going on break taking
E5 playing Rook A1 you do it feels NE to
take on e4 because with the X-ray along
the D file if you side step with the
queen I can still play F4 yeah yeah
because your your tactic of Knight take
C4 no longer works because eventually
the defile the defile opens and the G8
Rook Falls so you have to take on e4
here and we are very likely to enter in
into either this position or there is an
option for white to spoil the black
structure on the king side but that
allows The Rook to land on E2 that's a
dead draw if you give white an
additional Tempo here to play King F2
you are extremely interested you are
very very interested here but Rook e 2
just makes an immediate draw here in
fact the entire Queen side will
disappear in in very very quick fashion
I'm expecting uh Leon to take on uh D7
twice and perhaps play Knight takes E4
here or Rook takes E4 this is a very dry
position now they have approached that
position uh right up to Rook takes D7
and joy it is my pleasure to announce
that the 13th World chess champion Gary
Kasparov is here and ready to join us on
the show Welcome Gary thank you thank
you so am I too late so is the round
over you're almost too late Gary but
you're one of the great attacking
players Gary and we saw this move de E5
and I'm disappointed Gary that leavon
did not capture Bishop takes again
remember I'm watching you know I'm
watching on the internet and I'm just
behind so that's why you have to tell me
what happened after
B saw I saw Bishop F4 what Happ Bishop
F4 Bishop F4 after the move Bishop F4
came yeah C5 C5 Queen D2 D5 yes correct
C5 Bishop takes H6 yes please Gary
break this down for us we were just
looking at Bishop takes H6 G takes H6
has t to take Queen takes H6 Knight
Knight H7 H7 yes well we were looking at
Rook E6 but Knight
H7 I saw Knight H7 Knight H5 F6 I
thought ah Knight H7 Knight so this
these
the were the first moves that ran
through your mind okay that's yeah I
just wanted to to to have my queen you
know just defending the king so let
right Queen no but it's the yeah but
yeah it's
not Knight F5 followed by Rook 81 and we
continue slowly but it feels Knight F5
yes Knight F5 F6 Rook 81 yes yes F6 Rook
ad1
yes yeah I should probably go Queen F
Queen F7
[Music]
yes we
take take by by by probably Pawn Yeah
Queen
G6 Rook takes C5 though Queen yes yes
yes yes sorry sorry sorry that's Queen
Rook Rook C5 no no no yeah that's the
yeah
that's yeah maybe still yes very yeah
would have been a lot more exciting that
what then then what we're about to
witness I was having but after Rook E6
you play also Knight F5 yes of course
mhm
yeah Rook E6 yes take on H6 Rook E6
Knight F5 and then Queen G5 check
is Knight F5 well this this position we
actually were very interested in I it
just felt like the engines are saying
it's even Gary but but it's but even but
it's exciting exactly yeah it's and
maybe you like to be white in such
positions you you you feel is it
practical want to roll the you know as a
professional player you also know that
it's so easy to sacrifice you know other
other other people's
pieces as a professional chess
commentator it's my great honor and
Glory you finished the sentence yeah of
course we we have to we have to
sacrifice of course we do I I I think
white has excellent position so it's
it's very entertaining and I would say
very little risk yeah it's it's easy to
play with white it's easy to
even if position is even by m from
machines perspective so for
humans yeah and also what what was the
alternative I mean just two two the game
continuation unfortunately the
alternative is the game continuation
Gary and the game continuation is not
attractive at all what happened in the
game is all the pieces got traded off uh
leavon instead of sacrificing he took on
E5 Rook takes E5 Rook D1 and
unfortunately Gary we've seen this
throughout the tournament for leavon
he's not inspired his play is not
inspired him to
play and we will expect sometimes you
know is this it's this you um you have
players that are just getting tired of
the tournament and they want us to
finish it yes so it's the it's I I I I
remember that this this this V announced
comments when when this is the at the
end of our match in in in in New York
yes 995 so because I just you know I
want to make quick draw in the last game
was white and and he was asked so why
why didn't you try okay he was he was
losing minus three so it was clearly you
know that the match was over and and V
said you know put put put you in my
shoes so it's this how can you play you
know just you know I think he he just
something like nail
biting just he clearly didn't want to
anymore so let's get out of here yeah
exactly so uh yeah uh so I think it's
Leon probably had no no energy it's just
to to go for it I but still I would
think it's if the tournament goes poorly
why not to take on A6 have fun exactly
exactly and also we will be happy we
will be rooting
where uh Gary I I I what what else
happened there because I saw I saw I saw
yeah it's okay it's a draw just take it
take it away uh for me Gary I wanted to
ask you a question uh I refer to the
game between nepo and Anish for a moment
if you don't mind cuz what happened in
this game was actually extraordinary
seriously it's not a joke Neo played 20
moves and had 96 Minutes it just like
blitzing blitzing blitzing Anish was
taking his time taking his time the gap
between them became an hour and I began
reflecting on the fact that I once
played against vishi and nand where the
difference in our clocks was even closer
to two hours what has been the worst
example for you where your opponent just
Blitz throughout the whole
game um
um I'm not so sure not so sure
not you got stopped because you need you
need there are very few players who
could actually who could Blitz their way
through VI was one of them this game has
finished just just to interrupt you
sorry Gary but we do have a handshake
between leavon and the lanir our
congratulations to the wild carder
finishing with plus
two yes please sorry uh do continue Gary
uh
um you know it's this it's not about the
game but it's just it's the uh but uh
you mentioned Vish yes so
uh I think it was our
first classical chess game we played in
um
linaris in uh
91 yeah yeah L 1991 so and uh it was
petro and uh um I I was very happy
because it was a really tight tournament
so I started po I lost to but then I
just you know I was gradually catching
up and with um three rounds to go I
think three round yes three rounds to go
so I think we were we were EV so and I
had I had to play vishi luo and and yup
and two whites so and I was very
optimistic so I think three rounds to go
yes yeah um and uh I we had um was wish
we had petro and I followed now analysis
because we prepared this line for kpov
90 so uh and we found some new ideas I
remember work with Sergey delat this is
the it's the it's a third move d4 so
it's this very long line and um vishy
played you know by you know just all the
theoretical moves and then just you know
reach the position and I was already
sitting you know wa okay now this is
this analysis it's everything should
work in my favor and vishy just for
couple spent couple of minutes a very
and he played that remember Rook takes
D2 so this is It's returning the
exchange so this and and I just you know
it would play so quickly again it
doesn't solve all the problems but I
would really annoyed by him playing so
quickly and I just you know I made a
mistake and he escaped and was a draw
and and it's you know that's that's what
I ended up actually I beat luo but then
I just I uh Drew was L and even took won
the tournament first tournament I I have
not won in since since 1981 so um and
and that's you know it's it was only one
move but still you know is you know the
confidence that he made a move I
remember Rook takes D2 I just you know
yes caught me by not surprised but again
was annoying very annoying I want to
turn your attention to the game of
Fabiano and Richard report still but
it's it's yeah he played very quickly
but the position I saw will look very
good for white which one the uh the NEPA
position ah the Nea position he SP he
spent a little time but you know it
looked at his position was I mean was
considering the time you spent you know
was too good right yeah um Peter jump in
uh what's just happened things are
actually getting quite interesting there
because uh Anish is now because of the
pressure on the clock Yan is still above
an hour and is is down to 3 minutes only
uh but he's only need needs to make two
more moves and he played a good move
here Rook B3 which I think requires a
lot of calculation because you need to
worry about 95 after 95 your pieces are
still are still hanging there's ideas of
Knight takes G4 and Rook H1 check6 F6
yes I think both Knight C8 and Knight G6
are okay F6 might still no hang on F6
Knight takes G4 sorry sorry yeah so he
will have to choose between Knight C8
and Knight G6 both of which are okay
Knight C8 very specifically because
after Rook F7 the Knight Returns to the
game with great effect attacks The Rook
on F7 attacks the pawn on e4 but if this
were move 35 this would have been very
very exciting and also very promising
for Yan I think but with only two moves
to make it feels like Anish will
probably uh be okay but yeah Yan managed
to generate a lot of excitement from a
position which we thought was quite dry
so yeah I think he he's played a
surprisingly interesting game today from
uh what looked like uh a very level
situation yeah and what about the game
between Fabby and Richard because this
game has much more energy uh Jo I mean
look more pieces on the board also if
abano wins and he will be seeing Phil
cop winner out right as well uh night
just take us H how would you break down
the position between Fabby and Richard
exactly at this point we just saw the
move Knight F3 to G5 I'm not sure about
Richie's move Bishop f8 by the way
but how do you how do you like them
apples
Gary why this why is slightly better
that's clearly and no doubt about it
okay so U so I I guess that he wants to
play Knight E4 yes now yes I wonder I
wonder why you play Knight
G5 Knight G I don't know it's sort of
annoying okay maybe okay you don't
expect H6 night takes A6 I mean I'm sure
that would be nice you don't expect you
don't expect H6 so then why do you play
Knight G5 so what what is now your
knight doing on
G5 it's there
H4 potentially my queen could come over
to F3 okay I don't say there's a rook
lift in the position but is this a is
this not okay let me make a bad move
sorry uh let me make a bad move take
take let me make some more bad moves
Rook D3 Knight here and now we stop
because we've got checkmates down the H
file uh I I leave the details to
yourselves but uh Knight H7 Rook H3 I
sacrificed my queen yeah but Rook H3 H6
actually you have to make sure it works
uh Rook H aha that's a Pity but there
how about Knight H7 unfortunately
there's a bishop H6 included somewhere
we take on C2 we take on C2 and after
Knight F6 we actually go into the corner
not to G seven you do what we go we go
into the corner I no no sorry I go
Knight F6 check of course King H King h8
unfortunately yes yeah it's The Rook on
A1 is hanging otherwise you could have
won the queen but Rook on A1 is hanging
and now Bishop H6 years yeah and I I
free the f8 square to run
yeah actually variation I have F6 I was
getting very excited there for uh the
idea of going Rook takes H6 here King G7
Knight G4 and then Bishop F6 but there
will be F7 F6 there yeah yeah KN G4
check I think king of fath might
actually be losing king of fa Bishop F6
king55 and this I was so excited about
this oh but this unfortunately does not
quite happen because you both spotted F6
check yeah F6 here probably solves all
of these it's an answer to the check
sorry does it though Bishop than hang on
a second the but it's it's still it's
still a draw is yeah I've got to
prepare it's a king F7 Rook H6 Rook H7
and you have to go King
G8 uh yeah King 8 95 is still made yes
95 still made what's the difference I
mean before exists but yeah it's bad
okay uh so you have to go back and then
we're going to make no hang on a second
Rook G7 King h8 King H King h8 no king
h8 is made no no King f8 King f8 King f8
uh yeah you have to go King f8 and I
wanted to go Knight H6
uh I wanted to go like full
on you you both read the same
te but this is still a draw of the king8
unfortunately still a
draw uh so this is why I think Knight G5
is and Fabby he's got these ideas of a
rook lift a Rover Rook up and over
Knight G5 and he's trying to be annoying
psychological yes because because you
know uh uh uh Rober you know is just
he's very aggressive player and uh and
maybe now he he's seeing some some you
know hallucinations now it was night on
G5 was just yeah so by did play A5 no no
he played Knight G4 which is a good
reply I think Knight G4 uh Gary uh sorry
we've got uh people in studio W waiting
to be interviewed tell us when you're
coming to town and you're going to be
joining us for the gay correct tomorrow
of course tomorrow tomorrow yes yes
tomorrow by lunchtime yes so I just have
one quick question I'd just like to ask
your opinion on so uh who do you think
will make it to the candidates we've
seen so so much speculation this is so
yeah but it's I think it's about
mathematics now so I'm not following the
details because it's about ratings it's
and then a fe the points I don't think I
I I can tell you that this you have to
ask you know the the the book not
me on that note thank you very much Gary
for joining
us tomorrow at the Gaya second of
December is the gay exactly thank you uh
Gary and we're gonna CH it to Anastasia
who's in studio uh with a special guest
Anastasia over to
you thank you yes sir and I have L with
me today L just finished your game in a
draw but first of all like what approach
did you have today while you were doing
the opening choice I mean such an
important game for you yeah well I uh it
was very simple just to play normal what
I intended to play anyway so in terms of
the opening I didn't really consider it
going uh crazy or or anything like that
I was just trying to play a good game
and um yeah I guess uh not much was
going on very solid game yeah so um
actually like can you please describe
let's say what happened with wor simply
like uh position was kind of equal yes
from the beginning yeah it's it's a very
solid line I mean black has uh such a
sound position that you can generally
speaking play uh um almost what you want
of course uh White is always having a
slight initiative but um I I don't think
I had any any troll uh he he at some
point he went for this knight2 Knight F1
idea yeah and and then yeah white gets
D4 Knight G6 Knight G3 B5
F3 and yeah and I was playing for D5 so
Rook a d8 d takes C5 I guess I could
take with a pawn here this is also
pretty solid I mean queen D7 and then
for example Knight D7 also some kind of
end game I thought maybe he can hope for
something but uh yeah again black is
very very solid so I decided to play uh
more concrete Knight E5 aiming for the
D6 D5 break and then then it was a bit
more here
uh more concrete uh of course Bishop
main idea is that after D5 white takes
on E5 and then plays F4 E5 and get some
some
Advantage um that's why I play the move
C5 uh Knight G6 was possible to but then
Bishop E3 D5 Bishop D4 and here I wasn't
sure I was calculating something like um
because if D4 Bishop F6 obviously and
after Queen C6 I thought E5 Knight D7
and Knight H5 and it's very tricky
because now E6 is coming and F4 as well
and if I take on E5 there is F4 and G7
fall so this kind of ideas um uh he was
trying to to trick you somewhere
actually to Tri me somewhere but the
position is so solid I mean that it's
it's very hard to so I think C5 is a
good move just denying the bishop to D4
square is gr some space in the center
like this I can play Queen C6 sometimes
sometimes immediately D5 and then after
Queen D2 D5 I think uh yeah it was this
line was I guess critical but it didn't
look uh good because I have Rook E6 and
then after Knight F5 Knight E8 protect
G7 he can play Queen G5 here because
Knight G6 uh I mean Rook G6 uh Knight D7
but uh after King f8 I thought uh
position should be fine for black and
and it's also a bit risky because um
after all a it's a piece yeah so
something like this I was I would be
very happy to get because I I would even
get chance to play for a win but uh yeah
after after Bishop takes E5 and and Rook
81 uh then a draw it's pretty much uh
inevitable yeah and uh did you were you
following also the game of Fabby at this
same time while you were playing yours
or you Tred to concentrate on only on
your yeah no not I would say not much
difference let's say if we compare with
the previous round I'm always interested
in in the rest of the games but uh not
especially I mean I know it's going to
be um a tough game I mean richer is a
although he's not having the best
tournament he's still a very strong
player and he's capable of um of winning
against anyone so it's it's a tough game
in general and um let's have a quick
look what's going on what do you think
about yeah looks U unclear to me seems
that black is doing fine but white is
also maybe doing fine so I guess I guess
yeah it's it's pretty even yeah yeah so
now it's interesting situation like if
Fab makes a draw then you have to play
this playoff like what's your plan now
what are you going to do yeah well first
of all I mean um it was a good
tournament for me no matter what so plus
two undefeated in this field it's great
so congratulations actually yes it was
really good event um yeah I couldn't ask
for more so uh but I still have chances
so if if I eventually get a chance to to
play for for the for the first place in
the playoff I'll I'll try to to do my
best and to use my chances yeah and now
also this all the situation with the
candidate spot and uh today was also
this clarification from F about the
rules what do you think about it and
yeah well actually I had little time for
for all this also it was a bit
surprising as I told you yesterday I
wasn't um I mean I was aware of vaguely
of the idea but uh uh I didn't expect it
to be so close and um and yeah so I I
had time to to check what the uh the
statement put forward by F and I saw
then uh some comments Chris for example
was commenting that uh uh this wasn't in
the original rule so if that's the case
that's of course not great from F but I
I mean again I plan to kind of after the
tournament I you will think about I'll
think about all this and and see what uh
what what should I do if your only
chance is to play some events outside of
us are you going to do so probably yes
yes because it's uh I mean it's a it's a
nice chance I mean it's not so I mean
it's not every day obviously that you
get a chance to to fight for for a place
in the candidate so yeah I I would do it
that's great great news we still don't
know what will happen afterwards let's
wait for the game of Fabby to to finish
and thank you so much L for all your
comments and congratulations once again
it was a great event thank you thank you
thank you Anastasia and we would like to
add our congratulations also to lanir a
fantastic result I mean just fantastic a
wild card coming in in and competing
with this field undefeated plus two as
he said simply outstanding I mean our
performance and as Anastasia mentioned
everything hinges on Fabiano's game of
course if Fabiano wins then he is the
outright sinkfield Cup winner but if
it's a draw we will see playoffs
playoffs and if he were to lose then of
course lanir would be uh a winner
speaking of winners mvl is now confirmed
thanks to Leon's draw yes thanks to
Leon's draw uh mv's spot in the top
three of the grand chest T is guaranteed
so that means that mvl will get an
automatic invitation a qualification
into next year's Grand chess tour cycle
and uh let's remind ourselves of the
grand chest standings Fabiana Caron he
came into the competition with 33 Points
11 points ahead of Maxine vasra he put
on a sterling performance and he was
assured Grand chest T Champion two
rounds ago but there was everything to
play for in the battle for second and
third and wle so going into this round
had definitely clinched a top three
spots exactly but uh it was unclear who
would be finishing in third place but
now we know Maxi
vasra uh by virtue of his draw over for
Ali Raza but also once again by virtue
of the fact that
um leavon leavon Drew against L because
the only other person who was in
contention was npom AI but NPI could
only claim the third spot from mvl if
himself won and lvon beat lener but that
didn't happen as we saw exactly and what
do you have for us in the game between
uh this BEC very very interesting coming
to to fa's game Janan game is also now
very sharp but appears to be kind of a
Sharp end game which with good play
should end in the draw still even though
Yan did a fantastic job of uh turning a
very symmetrical looking position into
an absolute mess much credit must go to
him there but Anisha is playing very
well in response but this one this one
is hitting up because after ight G4 and
after I think sadly uh Gary's initial
Instinct was as usual absolutely correct
I think KN G5 has genely played with the
intention of just fighting for the C5
square and your mating variations were a
little bit uh fanciful but fun but very
fun to walk to walk through 97 and 9 G4
were two of the best moves in the
position and after Bishop G3
interestingly the engine very much likes
the idea of Shifting this knight from F6
to F5 to generate more actual play
against the pawn on D4 Bishop G7 isn't a
mistake as such although
already here there were suggestions that
maybe knight6 was more precise uh
interestingly 5 just completely ignored
the idea of going Knight A4 which after
Queen B5 Knight C5 could lead to some
very interesting positions very often on
my screen I saw white actually getting
to sacrifice this piece on A6 BL could
become very very concrete but instead of
all
this uh Five played Knight
F3 and Richard very quickly played Rook
C8 here which I think is an accuracy uh
I think once again it was time to play
kn H6 to start immediately playing
against the D4 pawn and play could
continue something like Knight A4 Queen
B5 Knight C5 and I want to establish
that this is something we've been
wanting Yanka was arguing for this hours
ago correctly
correctly and if you do nothing actually
very often the idea of playing A4 and
then Rook A3 B3 this queen doesn't have
very many squares okay so specifically
here you're just in time to play Knight
F5 and after Bishop B5 you're actually
in time to take and if white takes with
the pawn suddenly you've lost connection
between your pieces and it will start
being awkward and if you take with the
knight uh you can start attacking the
the D4 Pawn by let's say Knight F6 and
then the Rook comes to D5 the other one
comes to d8 so there's enough play
before white manages to do something on
the queen side Rook A8 is slow though
and I think Knight A4 here followed by
Knight C5 would have been quite
awkward uh suddenly and it's been around
equal for quite some time with the
engine not really giving way more than a
minuscule Advantage somewhere here it
starts saying that let's say we play
Knight H6 A4 Queen B6 we include Bishop
B5 and then we start playing Rook A3 and
it starts actually disliking this for
black quite a bit because it seems that
the counterplay against the D4 Pawn Stop
is not fast enough you should be doing
it quicker but instead of all that I
played Knight E4 which is a similar move
of course and it has the the additional
additional idea of 9 D6 but it's not
really disturbing the queen on B6 that's
but once again I think uh Richie has
found himself in a spot where if he
continues not playing Knight H6 which
Remains the best move of here he might
actually be drifting into a position he
will stop
liking but do you think it's like Knight
H6 is like his Blind Side you know
because they often say that retreating
moves with the Knight very difficult to
see it feels like he's already passed up
on this opportunity twice right so
there's maybe some indication that he's
just not looking in that direction at
all that he's waiting for a good moment
to return it to F6 but if you put it on
F6 then your counterplay once again your
counterplay against the G4 Pawn is not
quick enough and here white even has
this very very cute move Knight E5
saying please take this one because I
will reestablish it with with a win of
win of a lot of material so this is
actually turning into a position where
you absolutely need to be precise with
black you no longer have the luxury of
just making Common Sense decision and
being certain that they will carry you
through and in terms of the clock
times 14 against 19 oh this is going to
be very I only just realized yeah and
they're only on move
21 so uh yeah in in this fight for first
this is going to get very very
intriguing in the remaining game between
let's take a look at that uh you were
you were giving uh kudos to uh Yan for
cre creating a bit of a chaotic mess and
he continues actually uh making the most
ambitious moves here uh we left it
somewhere here I think that was the
position I showed to Gary Rook B3 is the
correct response uh Knight E5 has been
played the Knight went to C8 and here
Yan could have played Rook takes F7 96
this leads to equal positions anyway but
he played Rook A4 which I think is a
good move stop well not stopping knight6
but protecting the E4 Pawn so that
knight6 is not that effective but after
F6 I think it was maybe time to uh you
know start liquidating the engine for
instance goes Rook D4 here once again
trying to stop Knight D6 from happening
and this all evens out because white
actually starts switching to the play
against the Knight on C8 and also very
very important to point
out that it might feel attractive in a
lot of position to give this check
trying to get get the king to occupy
poor squares but very often there is The
Rook H3 response that's so we play Rook
D4 and importantly if the Rook abandons
the uh the third rank we will now have
an additional resource of giving this
check we can also take on C7 and Chase
the Knight we can play King G3 get the
king up to G4 and play like this it
doesn't really leave the equality though
it's all very much within the margins
but Yan he finally I think spent quite a
lot of time thinking here this is move
42 by the way he's on 55 minutes and he
I have a feeling this is actually 55
minutes left over from previous so
that's actually that's actually an hour
and a half in real this is an hour and a
half whereas for Anish uh Anish is
playing on on the remaining 30 minutes
and he played a four
F5 uh yeah there is the you're right an
hour 20 he played a four of5 because
that's the most ambitious yeah I think
so because he is just making sure that
the pawn cannot be picked up by Rook F3
Rook takes F4 also there are checkmating
ideas on the board of Rook H1 which
you've highlighted and if the black Rook
is not able to intercept then the king
and the Knight if the king gets back
there's potentially a lot of trouble but
the engine says you can play Knight D6
now the point being the check can still
be replied to with Rook H3 and if Rook
takes C6 that's the one we can play B5
Rook D4 Knight C4 relocated to E5 the
king will come out by H6 and G5 this is
actually worse for white I I I I didn't
think I was getting the Knight to E5 ah
but we are nice Rook takes C6 is an
actual mistake here which you absolutely
should not be committing uh and on you
you have to credit Yan with ambition and
an attempt to make this into a very
double-edged game but he now it feels
like has to be a bit careful right
presumably if the Rook goes to D4 the
Knight goes to F7 uh the KN yeah this is
still okay but it's probably time to
pull the plug and get one pair of Rooks
off the board and without the pair of
Rooks the Knight is still very very
beautiful on E5 but we're probably not
going to lose this because the pawns
without the Rook will not be running
quickly enough so6 not play yet though
Anisha is still thinking has 26 minutes
has plenty of time to decide what we
have to go back to our game of the round
as a fobby playing for Clear first
Knight E4 and the players are down to 15
minutes and 14 minutes but they played
it so slowly Joy 21 moves and well this
is where nerves
and uh absolutely reform come into play
Richie's been in bad form let's just put
it like that but he has nothing to
lose when you have nothing to lose there
is a freedom there's no tension there
you don't care do you have that
expression when you have nothing to lose
you lose
it know I mean you know someone with
nothing to lose is unpredictable because
it's a dangerous
person nothing to lose talking about
nothing to lose uh we've been just been
given some really interesting final
round statistics do it and did you know
you probably knew this yes not been a
decisive game in the final round of the
sinkfield cup since
2019 but I know mvl defeated nepo in the
last round of a sink Phill cup and uh
here we go here you can see it uh giri
beat nepo in round 11 and Magnus Coulson
beat Maxim Vash Gro also in the final
round and the most decisive final round
was in
2018 with three out of five decisive
games fun fact that round featured a
Checkmate you remember that Yer no I
don't only five checkmates in the
history of the S cup wow the people are
fast to resign they don't they don't let
the checkmates true uh occur on the
board uh sorry we've got to drill down
more on this Fabby versus Richie game
because this is it it's entering that
territory uh Peter where I feel like
each move becomes that much more
significant yeah and also the clock is
very much ticking down uh Richard has
now overtaken Fabby or the other way
around I know whichever way you want to
look at it uh he's down to less than 14
minutes against fabi's 14 and is still
choosing a move and yeah this is this is
becoming surprising surprisingly tricky
uh to such a degree that I would maybe
be looking for for a whale for a way to
bail I am very in all of these positions
I incredibly attracted to the idea of
pushing C6 C5 but here uh the engine
suggests actually this is what I thought
was kind of okay but the engine suggests
that this Rook on the open B file is
actually very very strong and you
probably shouldn't do that even though
you might actually be making a draw with
this with this very precise move Knight
G4 F6 Within ention of meeting 96 and
here instead of resigning we have a
counter fork with knight3 and this
somehow survives but I think on 13
minutes uh actually choosing C5 because
you have to consider dc5 you have to
consider Knight take C5 which is also
very very critical and apparently the
solution is now to go kn3 which I didn't
even see I am just I hate having this
backward pawn and I like giving it up
for activity in particular for the
activity of the G7 Bishop it's once
again the Grom player and me kind of
spreading spreading his wings yeah I
love the move C6 C5 but not for anything
that you've said I if you're going to
play Rook A8 yeah and Knight D6 is going
to force you to go back to A8 you better
play C5 and justify putting the Rook on
C but here when it basically is
connected with a pawn sacrifice either
way you have to be very very certain and
yeah seeing 93 is not uh is not that
obvious although once you realize this
exists I think it's pretty clear that
you will be able to collect a lot of
material in response you will take on D1
you will then probably be able to launch
some kind of a strike against this kind
of a shaky Center should takes D4 coming
in right but yeah it's I think it's very
difficult to make this move on on short
time if if you had like 40 minutes here
and you could you know spend 20 of them
working out every detail maybe then
although if anyone is capable of doing
it as a kind of a semi Bluff Without
Really calculating everything through I
think Richie in particular in a kind of
a mediocre tournament where he is upset
about things and wants to play a
beautiful game right I think he is one
of those people he might be inspired how
pragmatic is it to burn time on the
clock in this particular position
completely wrong I would say right Ian
you have by the way C6 C5
veryy but but I mean if he because
without the move Rook C8 you would be
looking at Knight F6 you would be
looking at
but with the move Rook C8 and Knight D6
is is such a well I'm going to say
primeval threat simply a terrible threat
Knight D6 you have to justify the
previous move C5 the move that really uh
got my attention right here was when
Peter was saying well here here you
don't have to resign after oop sorry Bop
B
takes you start by GF yeah yeah I mean
it looks just awful you know until you
see the move Knight F6 and you go oh my
gosh that's a really really nice move
any trade of the nights is fantastic for
me as then it actually is a gr field yes
and then you're very happy but then you
go oh no it's terrible I'm lost after
the move Knight D6 because I'm losing
the bishop I'm losing the rook and then
you see the move Knight C3 and it's just
yeah and very practically just takes D
takes C5 I wonder if he had seen KN E3
and realized how playable w it was
wouldn't put it bust him f is playing
very very clean chess in this tournament
he's calculating extremely well and D4
takes C5 was played and I think it's
just also a practical decision because I
think these end games and here we go you
you you know you're you're not going to
be worse they're entering this
incredibly sharp tactical sequence but
both players are very good Jo at
calculating these lengthy variations
even when little time takes takes Bishop
B2 and this this is it this is the key
moment you must In This Moment play
Knight F6 I think any Retreats are just
and the reason for that is if you play
something like Bishop G7 yes after Rook
dc1 yes your pieces are just once again
this is uh there's a number of
variations in the grimfield where you
allow white to have this passer on C C5
if it's blockaded nicely in particular
by a knight on C6 it often doesn't go
any further and you're not even worried
but Black Knights are not really well
positioned to to block it and after Rook
dc1
it often actually reaches C6 and C7
because if you play Rook C6 here after
H3 let's say Knight gf6 Knight E5 your
pieces start getting pushed back and you
probably will not be able to establish
this blockade right so black survival
here really I talking about Survival by
this point I think very much hinges on
him finding Knight gf6 Ag and not
stopping after Knight D6 you you need to
tell yourself I have to continue
calculating this is not the end of the
game Knight C3 Knight C8 and we're not
taking on D1 either no no no no we're
taking on C8 oh yes Rook B2 Knight takes
D1 and once again this position as well
like if you imagine white somehow
lending Bishop E5 in yeah is going to be
very very bad scary here you'll think
it's quite scary right because Rook D2
you I was thinking Rook B8 but then then
you can go Knight C3 but then they start
jumping yeah exactly I just wanted to
point out after Bishop
B5 the Knight will come to E4 that's
nice and the other one probably drops
back to D5 start pushing it away with F6
so if you actually get here in your
calculations I think it's possible to
convince yourself this is fine probably
the critical Tri the one that I would
find the most scary is the with the
ideas of just pushing this forward and
and wait one second I just want to that
looks very scary but also what about
Rook
C2 Rook C2 I think Knight D4 is the
intention with the idea of following it
up C6 I think C6
interestingly the engine suggests we
even have time to play F7 F6 for now
taking away the E5 Square preparing to
play E6 C5 and eventually this knif will
will come to C3 I don't think if this is
very easy to find but luckily for us
with black we can also start by going
Knight DC3 much more practical I would
and then perhaps after let's say Knight
D4 we can go like Knight G3 HG play
Knight D5 and yes it's on C6 and not on
C5 but with the bishop gone you feel a
lot safer you feel like very often you
will be able to bring the king over and
you shouldn't be losing
this so many things to see I mean first
of all you have to like the one that
you're assessing with the bishop and
Knight versus the two Bish two knights
and just a free root for the past porn
and then you also have the possibility
of getting the Knight trapped yes and
you have to rescue that that's an awful
lot of things to see M and Peter sorry
Peter uh Richard is calculating those
variations because this is the key
moment retreating the bishop we think is
going to get him in a really bad Jam
whereas Knight F6 thank you Anish uh
Knight F6 uh solves so many problems
brilant and we we will swiech back to
that but I will just show the position
the current position in the uh Anish
game after 96 F5 kn6 un played Rook G1
which is one of the good moves in the
position using the fact that the PA on
G4 is currently difficult to uh and the
players are currently repeating yeah and
uh Anish correctly gets Knight to a good
square but now Rook D7 is a threat Rook
H4 Rook d8 is a threat so it it feels
like they will probably give a Perpetual
here it feels like a draw is about to be
claimed with a three move repetition yes
but uh what a fighting game of chess
that one turned out to be lot of
imbalances and sacrifices but yeah I
agree with you yes so we got to get to
the action well neppo uh is going to uh
uh get all the credit here for really
making a very interesting game and we're
just waiting for the handshake Anish is
calling over the
Arbiter yeah I think Yan really pushed
pushed the boat out in this one trying
to to play an exciting game actually
took a lot of risks strictly speaking
was I think in a lot of danger at at a
certain point in this game but it will
now uh be drawn yeah the Arbiters will
not go into and there we have the
handshake and we see the players
discussing there's only one remaining
game so there we see Nom actually finish
on 50% in the end and KN six has not
been played uh I was thinking G complex
Bishop it looked like it was a very very
difficult move to play in practice and
now Rook dc1 specifically Rook dc1 other
moves are also decent but this is by far
the strongest because you do need to
start start Sid stepping those Forks you
you you need to be able to play 96 next
move without having to calculate knight3
so I think it's a very natural move to
make as well I think Fabi will probably
make it and yeah it looks it looks very
very dangerous for black now I wouldn't
call it insurmountable but in particular
on low time with 9 minutes for the rest
of the the game for the rest of the
first time control 15 moves to make for
uh for Richard after ugan I think he
will struggle to I think practically
hold things together yeah I for me
practically speaking this is a terrible
position I mean terrible if it was my
turn you make a passing move like H6 can
just see how incredibly strong this past
Pawn is you don't have time to make a
blockade
whether it be on the C6 square or even
now with the bishop on the board on the
C7 Square so we were looking I think at
Knight F or Knight H6 what yeah
currently the best move by far is Bishop
f8 which basically allows the pawn to
get to C7 wow by far Bishop f8 this
bishop Bishop f8
H3 not even H3 first I think is
preferred you have to go to to to F6 and
why just and go C6 and you cannot stop
C7 but you can establish some kind of a
blockade on the C8 square and those
positions are not always completely lost
you play Knight D5 C7 Rook E8 and you
hope that eventually you will be able to
play F6 and
D5 but that's the hope the hope that
white doesn't doesn't actually get there
before you play F6 and E5 and disconnect
the bishop on G3 from the Pawn on c77 is
is
highlighting
lots of luck with that I mean it just
feels like it's all play on one goal it
is yeah it is you're absolutely possible
to go F6 and E5 and block out the bishop
well that that's what Peter is
suggesting is that after perhaps you can
include A7 A6 to make you take it on the
different Square so that your Rook is
not protecting C7 if I'm very lucky if I
don't immediately lose to Rook B1 Rook
B8 here for instance and now I want to
play F6 let's say Rook takes A6 C5 and
if that happens maybe we don't always
lose with back right maybe there is some
chance because I want to start attacking
the C7 Pawn with everything I got Rook
dc1 played by the way Rook B1 C1 and uh
ye if Bishop f8 is the best move by far
in this
position uh that's well this is
desperate Straits for for Richard for
yeah I I feel I feel Bishop G7 was a big
blunder and a big mistake sry not a
blunder it's not possible to go Rook C8
sorry Rook C6 you can but it will get
shifted away way after H3 you will have
to allow Knight E5 and that's a
different flavor of yeah I was thinking
Knight
H6 I'm desperately trying to stop a
knight getting to E5 and D4 well but now
I guess Knight E5 Bish B5 Bish B5 is
also going to be incredibly painful with
the
night the beautiful Bishop uh reain
Supreme yeah this is also not going to
doesn't look good do it no it's Grim
actually it's simply grim
Bishop f8 I boy I I would be re
resistant to that Mo I mean F7
F6 maybe I but I
think the thing about playing F6 is
right this moment white hasn't committed
to C5 c67 yet so what might happen if if
we just switch for this for a second you
want F6 F5 but with the pawn still on C5
white could switch to doing things like
this stop it and just like entering with
everything yeah that's horrifying it's
just not great yeah no that's horrifying
and again I mean
Fabiano completely Stellar year wi
Bucharest we've talked about I mean this
could be the double exclamation mark on
one of the greatest Grand chest Tor
victories I don't think anybody scored
as highly and
actually we had this conversation
yesterday during the dinner and I think
Fabby said that uh there was a year
where Magnus won ABS 2019 I think the
suggestion was that Magnus if Faby wins
this he ends on 46 gr chestor points BR
brilliant which is an unbelievable
amount considering that there is only
four events you can play and the maximum
score is 52 right so he's got 46 out of
52 which frankly feels a bit U
superhuman right but uh apparently in
2019 the year Magnus hasn't actually won
the Tour because he lost the the final
knockout tie breaks to ding
right the system the scoring system was
slightly different and I Fabby at least
I think claimed yesterday that Magnus
finished at above 60 which honestly
simply means that they were giving more
points for a win because you can't get
the 65 it's just physically impossible
to get the 65 with the system of scoring
so the question I already asked on air
once is going to be difficult to answer
what is the record uh in terms of GCT
points over season because the scoring
system has not stayed exactly the same
uh year year after year but with the
current system of 13 for Clear win I'm
pretty sure 46 is a record which will be
uh there must have been moreen for for
for many many years there must have been
more Grand chest tour events that
particular or possibly The Knockout at
the end gave you more points because
yeah 65 is just not humanly possible
exactly and just you mentioned it yes
let's remind ourselves of the year of
Fabby well it started in Bucharest with
first place and then Croatia fourth
place and World Cup he secured his place
at the 2024 candidates tournament US
champion and just now became St Louis
rapid and Blitz champion and now 2023
grandchester Champion winning that one
with two rounds to spare total winnings
380,000 and remember first prize for
this event is $100,000 yeah can he add
that to his collection uh the trophy
room is going to be packed after this
Rook D1 C1 move and it took Fabby a few
minutes to play it I'm sure he felt that
he had other choices but after the move
Rook D1 C1 Richard there's a pause
there's a pause and it's very
understandable PA pause exactly cuz I
think Richard is only now realizing that
he's just not going to be on time to
establish any kind of a blockade or get
rid of of the E4 Knight he gone Bishop
H6 which is I guess understandable
trying to put the C1 Rook on a poor
square but C4 is just not the poorest
Square not at all no uh that's the kind
of move that you come to when you're
desperately searching for something that
you
know feels like everything else can
conventional moves all brought you
nothing Bishop H6 is a
move kind of like it because okay yes
The Rook goes to C4 but on the other
hand maybe there's some back rank issues
if white is not careful well wait a
minute just a second you've provoked
pardon me not you Richard has provoked a
move that I really like I'm now I'm
threatening Knight E4 to D6 which is a
Tempo Against The Rook thank you for
shifting M are you like like like like
my British shifting me to a better
Square The Rook C4 square and night B6
frankly okay you're welcome to play a
move like Knight B6 I'll shift backwards
to C2 in this case what is your Rook
Knight doing there what is your Bishop
doing there not very much not very much
after Rook C4 you're still supposed to
play Bishop F fate the but the position
actually deteriorated and I was trying
to understand why I think it's mainly to
do with the fact that uh if we continue
the same line as we were uh looking at
before uh here uh I'm not obliged to
play C7 immediately probably wasn't
obliged even there but here in
particular uh let's say KN B6 okay we
now have an additional option of
attacking the F7 Square Pawn because uh
The Rook has been lifted for us right by
the move Bishop H6 and if A6 now uh once
again yeah maybe the difference actually
is let me let me consult my my magic
screen why why wasn't this as strong
here I have a feeling that actually
having Bishop H6 in reserve may have
been very useful because if we go Rook
B7 here yeah it plays F6 it plays F6 and
it says uh this is semi
playable and why doesn't it do it here
with the Rook on C4 you've given me Rook
F6
now loses completely to Knight D4 and
then like it's just better positioned on
C4 for some reason than it is on C1 I
even having looked at this for a bit I
still don't quite understand why the
difference is so dramatic but I can I
can believe that the Rook on a more
active square is better position than on
the star Square well I mean even in that
position where you you you you had after
F6 you had ideas of Rook A4 as well as
even Rook H4 like with the Rook on C4
hang on a second I think I think we're
getting there so she s Rook D7 Rook
B8 Knight ahuh I think I think I finally
am am getting getting there so this is
the position with the Rook on C1 after
F6 C7 here it very much insists you
absolutely have to play Rook D7 and it's
sort of surviving there with a rook on
C4 in the same position if you play Rook
D7 here after Rook B8 and Knight D7
white has to move Rook
D4 which you've given them right for no
reason whatsoever and black is not in
time to play 6 C5 you have to take and
the Knight slides by lands on either B5
or c 6 or E6 even and white wins quite
comfortably so there is a very very
specific reason why this is actually
useful for white it's not it's not a
neutral move it it turns out to be an
actually very very useful thing that
white achieves yeah no I really felt
Bishop H6 was just wrong I thought
Bishop G7 was wrong and these two bad
moves is going to give it's going to
give Fabby the
championship it's looking that way but I
don't want to be too critical about
Richard's moose because you know I I
think it was very illogical to allow the
white porn all the way to C sa and to
bank on Surviving that one no he he was
playing it beautifully up to Bishop B2
Knight F6 was the move he had to when
his Bishop was on B2 Joe V playing
Knight F6 okay but here Peter was
showing us H3 being played right yeah
you start you start by playing H3 what
happens if Knight to D6 here which is an
idea that was shown to oh spasa no but
in this particular case you do have Rook
takes D6 yes that's the big diff right
Bishop takes Bishop takes Rook takes D7
you don't have to take here no Rook Rook
will lose because D7 is a queen but you
okay good you don't have to react you
can go like Knight H6 here and say that
this is an improvement because I will
actually get some time to get my pieces
on decent squares is it whoa I mean I'm
okay oh I've got a back ranked Nate
problem because I was about to play Rook
a A4 and uh KN the five yeah and yeah
and go to the seventh Rook A7 rook b7th
and go to the sth but okay but I like
the bishop f8 H3 variation H3 is good
even the immediate C6 is fine H H3 is
just stronger but C6 is also very very
strong right this moment right nothing
particularly wrong with it whatsoever
eight minutes for Fabby eight minutes
for 350 move 27 yes they move 27
but uh a lot of moves to be had and and
I remember it was a shack memory Dar off
here the SFO cup where
Richie made a nervy move with like a
second on his clock and you can see uh
Richard is feeling the pressure here as
he knows H3 or C6 put immediate uh
pressure on him I don't like his
position at all I think fby perhaps has
to fight the Temptation not to play or
to play Knight to D6 which as we saw
that's a big Temptation it's a huge
Temptation because especially as we saw
Peter indicate that Black's tactical
trick doesn't actually work exactly um
quick question for you I have this uh
what have I played Rook C5 I was just
being Rook C4 to A4 I was just being
cheeky I want you to take my PA to
F6 probably which Knight G I think G
Knight G to F6 things need to come home
yeah we we we can't really be Knight
takes F6 do I want to include Bishop H4
you probably do yeah yeah okay let me
include Bishop H4 which I missed if if
I'm entirely honest uh well you still
have King King yeah let's go G7 maybe
maybe I'm yeah it's not I mean
shockingly not Rook F4 doesn't force you
to resign no 95 even ex5 also yeah sorry
no I was I was thinking that you
couldn't take on C5 because G4 was
hanging uh but Knight F6 is a good move
Knight
F6 uh holds it all
together okay what else could fabbi be
thinking about how about Bishop
H4 uh questioning you what are you going
to do about Rook on
d8 Bishop H um the idea is if I can get
you to put Rook to D7 now I've taken
away your F6 R B8 exists I think the
argument against Bishop H4 is very
specifically Rook B8 in human terms at
least he play he play C6 yeah and okay
this gives us something new to discuss
at least because we've established H3 is
very strong but we have not looked at C6
in any kind of this was very strong too
it is yeah we we did no no I mean no we
know it's strong but we haven't really
put it on the board how strong is it
Peter Well it in terms
ofation it's it's still it's slightly
weaker than H3 but it's still very very
strong and in order to create a mess I
think you always start with F5 here for
black because this Knight needs to be
pushed away from D6 Square in particular
Knight E G5 is a very obvious pawns then
we stop this Rook from coming to B7 this
one drops all the way back probably and
here you can maybe hope to to introduce
some degree of Mayhem like you play Rook
E8 you are now threatening to play H7 H6
hint that the Knight on G5 being
misplayed you have to play Knight D4 uh
E5 Knight B5 is very very bad because
things are starting to collapse you can
include A5 F4 though trying to get white
to allow this for and this and this
forces this bishop to an H4 Square which
looks extremely awkward because like H6
G5 ideas and know introduced into the
game this all works out tactically but
this is a lot Messier I think compared
compared to what we were having on our
screens previously F5 F5 uh trying to
cause some chaos Knight E4 G5 as you
prescribed foll following the main line
so far Knight G5 Knight B6 I think
probably an important move here you can
play Rook E8 but allowing Rook B7
doesn't doesn't look like it's a recipe
for Success Knight
and uh well this feels like a disaster
but I mean
uh yeah keeping your nerves when you've
got just three minutes on your clock
$100,000 first prize uh you don't want
to spoil it either Knight E4 uh no other
move but Knight B6 yeah yeah that just
looks like it's
box does Knight B6 attacking The Rook
has the
move for Richard to survive well Richard
now ticking to under 3 minutes and
they're only on move
28 yeah what was your worst time trouble
period you had a situation where you had
to make 10 moves 20 moves in two minutes
or yeah some one of those horrible
horrible things you lose even track of
the clock you're just banging pieces
yeah I've entered into a period I call
the rust period the rust the rust where
you know this is actually one of the
problems with not playing so much over
theboard chess and just you you get
rusty and decisions take you longer and
uh you lose confidence in certain things
and so you often end up finding yourself
in these in these kind of situations and
now Richard is two minutes for 12 moves
and he has to find the counter attacking
KN R8 is not not a bad move it's one of
the two moves which were still playable
plausible it does invite Rook B7 the the
the reason I thought Knight B6 was
advised was to prevent The Rook from
entering I think that was a solid reason
and I would have preferred it but this
is still uh somewhat playable although
it feels like in many variations that
the computer suggests here as best play
for black you just have to abandon the
pawn on E6 in order to get some trades
on E E6 yeah E6 yeah you like for
instance one of the things that the
engine suggest is to play Rook E7 just
allowing Rook takes E7 and Knight takes
E6 just to get some pieces of the
board yeah yuck is yuck yuck is a very
appropriate reaction there I
think entirely appropriate that's not
the best tasting ice cream I ever had no
but isn't it more natural right after
Rook B7 to kind of go H6 attack the
Knight okay okay H6 h69 F7 is its own
set of problems because yeah I wanted to
see how bad it was
though I hear it PA just because it just
it I think he probably goes for this
though because it's a uh Knight let's
let's show let's show this on y board
Knight F7 and you have the option of
playing a four here MH and we take once
with the bishop okay and then after
Knight takes a four white needs to
realize that the setup is sturdy enough
to allow us to actually spend the tempo
on H3 right because Rook F4 Rook C6 I
think might become difficult to convert
because back rank issues give black some
hope at least but H2 H but H3 is very
very strong there and white is in a very
dominant position Rook B7 is late I'm
just going to refresh my board but it
was Rook B7 by the way on the board by
Fabby and again we're looking
at H6 Knight F7 F4 o but the
is telling us that the best defense is
Rook
E7 the best sacrificing Al giving up E6
Pawn yes just giving up this Pawn on E7
and by the way I do I need to be so
compliant I mean
uh you know I love grabbing pawns don't
get me wrong Rook E7 creates the idea of
Rook takes C6 the reason you maybe need
to C in thank you thank you that clears
some cobwebs yes okay Rook takes C6 is
not cuz I
thinking do I have time to play H3 for
example you know one of those you're
still better after H3 but it's it
becomes a bit more manageable for black
I think E7 is the harshest yeah Rook
takes E7 Bishop takes E7 Knight takes E6
I fall for your nefarious plan of
getting me a pawn ahead
yeah and one minute apprach it's just
obviously the the pawn six cannot really
be attacked we can uh safely assume
white keeps it these types of end games
are are bad it's just a a very clear
indication of how dire the situation has
become for Richard that this is the
prescribed course of action instead of
Rook E7 you can go Knight
gf6 but then after Bishop
E5 uh very often the Knight on G5 just
goes to F7 when it's
chased and on F7 it's very difficult to
challenge because uh it's there yeah
it's just there and uh yeah this is this
is pretty bad this feels like mud 30
seconds and that's a big indication that
nothing has gone well for Richard and
they're still only on move 29 and now
was ticking down to 20 seconds bear in
mind that Richard does get an additional
30 second per move this is the current
situation after Rook B7 Rook
E7
kn7 doesn't look doesn't look good yeah
Knight E7 that no no with the pawn
getting to C7 now we include H3 and and
then after H3 Knight F6 we we have an
absolute free reign to do pretty much
whatever we please Knight D4 for
instance is very strong Bishop B5 is
very strong this will collapse now yeah
Knight E7 and we are we are seeing
Fabby crowning himself I mean this is
just a all play on one goal now as uh he
has an overwhelming position with his uh
pass Pawn on the SE file his Superior
pieces just look at you know just
compare the pieces everything that black
has one s white piece every single white
is better is better than its black
counterpart exactly exactly so it's just
it's it's overwhelming and then the at
in the clock times including the king
safety and yeah but okay talking about
the clock times Fabiano doesn't have
that much time either I know his
position is overwhelming it should be
relatively easy to play convert yes but
you're right I mean there it's always
that butt you've got three minutes you
you start to see a ghost or two here or
there you get a little nervous should I
be playing C7 Knight takes E6 or not C7
also completely winning but I think
including H3 Knight F6 makes a decent
amount of sense yeah just to make sure
we have access to the E5 Square as well
I like age3 because it takes care of the
king as well Bingo that's what I was
waiting for King safety no more back
rank mates you take over
the yeah the only issue for for for f
here is just the the width of choice the
the wealth of choice has on every move
and everything everything looks winning
it does uh so you might just struggle to
to to pick but apart from that I think
it's
just he here here I have the uh choice
of Knight D4 as well as
C7 um if you're going to CH I don't
think I'm playing C7 at all I think I'm
keeping it on C6 I I like that on C6 the
reason I like it on C6 finnally enough
is I do like this uh Rook on the seventh
rank absolutely and Knight
D4 uh we could also find ourselves
having a mating attack at some point
just randomly just randomly having a
mating attack to go with everything else
yeah we don't have to promote our pond
to a queen we can check made and
set it really reminds me of that phrase
that white is a porn up and has the
compensation and has the compensation
yeah me this position is just
overwhelming truly for White Knight D4
play
WoW and 20 seconds there for Richard
report and yeah this this this just
looks bad so let's just watch uh rard
try try to find moves on 10 seconds it's
not it's not really going to be very
pleasant for him I assume something goes
to D5 or you H6 Knight G6 can you yeah I
think we can take on A6 because Knight
takes E6 doesn't work maybe he thinks
Knight takes uh C6 will work in response
but his position just collapses he
doesn't lose a full piece but the
position collapses after uh Knight f8
and then we take on G6 and we just cash
in in the other direction Knight takes
C6 we go Knight f8 Knight D4 we take on
C8 we take on
G6 we are currently one Pawn up but we
also actually have that maing attack
that we were describing with the bishop
coming to E5 with Knight D7 being a
threat with Rook takes A7 being a threat
oh dear this is just very very bad for
black that looks absolutely dire for
black but it does involve this switching
of plans you know White's idea here is
to obviously Preserve and maintain that
pawn on C6 how findable is it just to
capture a porn unfortunately for for for
for Richard very if you just go night
gf3 you're also completely winning so I
can decline to calculate and say my
position is overwhelming I I'm just I
don't need to involve myself with any of
those conrete varations that hard though
I'm playing Knight takes E6 uh with
Glee uh just because again uh I'm taking
the G six Pawn which just absolutely
destroys the structure on the king side
it looks winning and he goes for It Go
of course you always look at checks and
captures and threatening moves first and
this move Knight takes E6 Knight takes
E6 very easy to calculate KES C6 he
actually finds himself in a situation
where only one move wins but it's the
move he most likely will play because
nothing else really makes much much
sense uh but yeah that nothing else
really does does the job at all apart
from night no not as well at all at all
you throw it away if you don't take on
the F okay and you have to take on D4 I
take on C8 and this is where I was
saying that by capturing the pawn on G6
I've absolutely destroyed wrecked
Black's pwn uh kingside structure 97
check as mentioned big threat of a fork
and most saliently Bishop E5 ouch
how
are n takes there we have it 94 needs to
be played no choice once again for for
Richard at least he will gain some time
on the clock as some measure of Mercy
but and this
is look how useful H3 is turning out to
be we no longer need to worry about our
King's safety yeah and again I could
take on D4 but allowing you to take and
I'm a pawn up but no I really want to I
really want to wreck the king side side
pawns and capture the pawn on G6 so we
do expect Knight takes D4 yeah this will
happen Rook takes C8 and Knight takes G6
yeah and Fabby is putting the finishing
touches on Fab
element definitely this his kind of
position anyone's kind of position to be
honest absolutely and he will play this
so he plays these technical positions so
very well Rook takes Rook Rook takes C8
yeah
once again no choice
for for Richard you have to take on C8
Knight G6 and you desperately want to be
able to generate some activity on the
other side Knight E2 yeah but the King
on H2 is very very safe I don't think I
need to worry about F5 F4 at any point
no and you can't even you don't have
enough time to pick up the bishop
because of the fork on E7 constantly
being threatened annoyingly for for
black exactly knight7 check F5 Pawn
seconds seconds but it's no longer about
the clock it's definitely about the
position we saw Richie having to resign
uh was it against Len
doming in that caroan turn French that's
what he's thinking about right 5 seconds
he knows okay there goes Rook
C8 Knight takes
G6 yeah nothing to
discuss yeah I guess if you want to
continue you play something like Knight
C6 but then pretty much anything wins
Bishop B5 wins Knight H4 wins you you
you have a choice of very very pleasant
options here white is uper Pawn
completely dominant every single light
Miner piece better than its counterpart
the good news is Knight C6 does stop
Knight E7 losing The Rook the bad news
is it doesn't prevent Knight H4 and Rook
c one check it's good for 30 seconds
it's good for 30 seconds but I think it
you see simplifies the conversion now
because now knight6 I think loses a
piece to Rook C7 and there's no defense
against Rook takes C6 and the fork on I
know there's Knight D5 there is a
defense but I have Bishop F4 takes H6
which which will decide the game exactly
and then the black king on G8 completely
boxed in truly 12 Bishop E5 down is
Desperado Time 4 seconds three seconds
oh Knight C6 one left he does go he does
go ni six one second there's the the
infamous 31 seconds Jo on the clock uh
we've seen that more often than we'd
expect to uh you were mentioning Rook C7
I'm thinking Knight H4 I'm me Knight H4
is good Bishop F4 is good Bish F4 is
nice as well Bop F4 isy takes Bishop
takes H6 and Rook G7 I've got a rook G7
checkm exciting you're right Bishop F4
apologies that is not only grabbing a
pawn actually attacking The Rook as well
yeah and it's a mate threat too uh with
Bishop takes uh H6 behind it I think all
of the moves we've named so far are
completely winning so it's just a matter
of taste what Fabby prefers
here what's your guess Joy Bishop F
Bishop F4 think so as well yeah I think
it's the CLE
well I'll go with Knight H4 just to be
on the other
side the table here Knight H4 I you know
there something special about those F5
and F6 squares you
know yeah and there we see Fabby take
down to under two minutes who did we
recently had a nearly winning position
didn't lir yes L eventually made a move
on one second against Anish in the game
that he won yeah he himself said he was
completely shocked by the fact
that he he thought he had lot of time
and then he didn't yeah he just made a
move and then looked at this clock and
then realized right oh my goodness made
that move with one here's Fabby ready to
pick up a $100,000 prize uh first prize
could he forget his clock no no no no
the answer is no
no minute n he's using every every part
of that 30C bonus by I guess now is the
moment when you realize that Victory is
there at your fingertips and it's the
moment where you potentially get over
excited and can ruin things so good idea
just to take a second breath and uh have
a look around which move number is this
by they are on move 36 so uh 4 seconds
40 seconds
okay Knight H4 is but Bishop F4 you
right the end very very well spotted to
you
both and it did gain uh Fabby the 30
seconds and Bishop takes H6 mate and one
you can't argue it with them apples no
you can't Knight E8 forced defending G7
yeah and now you can even go 97 check
frankly I think the maybe the cleanest
is just to go 97 Check and Go the A7
Pawn as well collect absolutely
everything I love that move because that
you get in the Fisher ending of rook and
Bishop to begin with but you're two
pawns up I mean there there's no ending
it's just Knight
E7 yeah yeah absolutely yeah I think
this reaches more 40 and then Richard
takes stock of uh the disaster the ruins
of his position and the game probably
ends
and now Fabby is under the minute yeah
but of course Knight
E7 an easy find for Fabiano you have to
take there's really no choice no choice
you probably go Knight D6 here and uh uh
the cleanest way I think is you include
Rook G7 check to put the King on a dark
square h8 is you might even include Rook
D7 here because uh you want to restrict
the Knight as much as possible it really
runs out of squares actually you can
actually not avoid putting it on the C
file because after Knight E4 F3 you
really struggle to find a square you
will like including always that A7 and
having cleaned up everything having
protected a two with Tempo I will
eventually pick up on A7 and continue
and KN C4 I think we go Rook C7 I think
we go Rook C7 here pin yeah and we look
at our opponent
[Laughter]
quizzically exactly yeah my my
absolutely alltime alltime favorite uh
uh anecdote about Victor kcho comes to
mind yeah do speak English yes Yanka
looks like she may not have heard this
one before so you do know the you know
the one we're referring
toai you know I've heard many stories
about him but Richard now
ohing given us something to yeah and now
after something like B B3 you might not
even get the position we were discussing
you might be in more trouble than you
were previously I think Bish B3 might
might win a piece yeah Bishop E3 just
there's Knight D6 so maybe Bish Bishop
F4 maybe to stop Knight D6 from
happening and then Black's position
completely collapses it feels like
Knight takes F5 CH he's reaching for the
bishop Bishop e he's allowed Knight D6
which is ah he has Rook C7 there it
doesn't matter has Rook C7 yeah nothing
nothing really matters
here um Rook C7 I thought I thought
Bishop 4 was a bit cleaner because we
don't want to be allowing Knight D6 at
all but it it shouldn't and it won't
matter exactly yeah and as you know and
there we have you have it
wow congratulations is the sinkfield Cup
winner what a performance what a game he
actually broke a small little record
there has not been a decisive game in
the final round of the sinkfield since
2019 well
now
2023 he broke a smile the very end also
if I have not misheard there was a very
interesting little tidbit uh in the
interview with Gary which kind of I
brings me uh to mind considering the
year that uh Fabby Fabi had I think Gary
said that that tournament in NS 991
where he actually remembered all the
last three opponents and the colar and
everything I was just standing there
thinking how right Ivan was leading I
had to play vishy I got luo in it's been
30 years how do you remember that I got
V then at the end he said I did not
catch up to ivanchuk and that was the
first tournament I didn't win since 19
81 for 10 years and the the kind of a
dominant performance Fab has had this
year sort of brings me uh reminds me of
the the best years of Gary when Gary was
winning absolutely everything and our
congratulations absolutely he's won it
all and this year he became singfield
Cup champion Grand chestor Champion St
Louis rapid and Blitz Champion I mean St
Louis is just his lucky place what a
performance as WC Fields would say all
things considered I'd rather be in St
Louis I mean and a replay if you don't
mind me saying of OI Raa one year ago
did exactly the same thing Ali raaza
came he saw he conquered he won the
rapid and Blitz he won the SV cup he won
the grand chest tour and in the same
style Fabby did the same thing we're
going to go to Tony Rich at the World
Chess Hall of Fame for a Trophy award
over to you Tony well It Feels Like Only
Yesterday we were here with Fabiano
handing him another trophy in fact you
know was more like nine rounds ago where
he won the St Louis rap and Blitz
Fabiano congratulations on winning yet
another tournament singfield cup uh I
just have one question cuz I know
they're going to talk to you in studio
and my question is you going to leave
any trophies for anybody else this year
well I think this year I did an Ali Reza
because it's exactly what he what he did
last year so I'm I'm very happy of
course it's uh more better than I could
have uh dreamed of it's it's an amazing
result for me well congratulations once
again thank
you o oh oh that's how it
works a beautiful
c
m you see that's the problem when you
don't allow the spectators into the
playing Hall you don't get this
thunderous Applause for a job
extraordinarily well done and as we wrap
up our uh uh broadcast uh we're going to
get Fabby so I just want to give a big
shout out to the players first of all
and there we see our s Cup champion but
also to thank the people at the St Louis
chess club absolutely and Scholastic
Center for all of their work and making
our job so easy World Chess Hall of Fame
where they're hosting silver back silver
back and all the production team for
being absolutely marvelous and of course
we cannot forget to thank Rex and jeie
for absolutely their support of final
standings let check out the final
standings and here it is in all its
Glory Fabiana Carana wins the sinkfield
cup takes 13 Grand chest T points and
$1,000 in second place he had the
performance of his lifetime lenia
Dominguez undefeated at the SFI cup he
takes 10 grandchester points and 65
why couldn't I have tied for first and
made a
playoff and in third place it was Wesley
so with four and a half points out of
eight and
48,000 to the good a lot of players Yan
leavon MV all finished on uh 50% uh
leavon did it in a different way for Yan
I think he will be disappointed for MV
as well didn't win any games and you
know Peter you want to win win a game
you absolutely want to win a game and uh
of the three of our players on 50% Leon
actually won one but if you compare the
tournaments Yan and MBL have played I
think Yan will feel that he came very
very close a number of times generated
chances generated a lot of ideas
generated excitement but still a draws
out of eight he'll be uh disappointed
with that
absolutely and here are some stats and
there a mighty impressive stat as well
well Fabiano breaking a grand chest T
record because Fabiano now holds the
record for the most points in any Grand
chest with the four evance he got 46
points because he won the sink field cup
out the
bonus we did see that uh Magnus Carlson
did get
67.5 points in 2019 but then the tour
featured six Evans and higher Point
offerings so Fabiano Man of the Year
what can we say about his performance
his play especially in the second half
of the singfield cup it just got better
and better it for me it was
extraordinary because the great test
that Fabby had uh with duda's withdraw
he got this very very unfortunate
sequence of having three consecutive
games with the black pieces and not only
did he overcome that he won he won one
he won one of them against yesterday
yesterday years not yesterdays the
previous year winner of everything he
bit res in that extremely exciting very
very sharp game that they played a
couple days back arguably maybe the game
of the tournament with the with the
amount of swings and turn
around and uh and there we I've got to
admire Anastasia you know hey I want an
interview with our winner she's making
sure that we get to talk I'm going to
grab you
Fabi and get him to share with us his
thoughts I mean I wonder he must be
feeling was very very very
happy uh officially the closing ceremon
where is it it's there you can see it a
strategy across the board it will be
held just before the Gaya at December
the 2nd at the Chase Park Plaza and
there will be the special guest Marina
toy who of course course is using chass
as an inspiration for her set and
costume design and we also saw that the
Brian Woods and Brian Owens are going to
be mcing that very spectacular event yes
along side Sharon Carpenter uh and of
course all the players will be
congregating there for that uh special
uh closing and the Gaya it's a very nice
um I want to say uh ending of the year
year where it's a fundraiser and there's
a silent auction so uh people can
participate in our fundraisers uh we
have our community outreach program if
there's any that you want to support
whether it be the World Chess Hall of
Fame the St Louis chess club our
outreach program there's tons of ways
for you to do it to do it as Rex
singfield would say no donation is too
small Absol or too large we accept
everything be a brilliant night it will
it will be very Gary Kasparov coming in
and Gary jump coming into town too
exactly just for the event yes as we get
ready uh for Anastasia to sit down with
Faby what would you like to ask him
Peter how do you do it how do you do it
how do you do
it also that as well yeah perhaps he
would like to to buy around too we're
always is open to that idea over here uh
but yeah it's just fantastic to watch
him in full flight and it's been it's
been a year to remember and uh well
Peter you can soon ask that question to
the man of the moment because Anastasia
is right there with Fabiana carar in the
studio exactly we just ran from the club
with Fabby Fabiano congratulations what
an impressive Victory and you have
immediately the question from Peter
Sidler who just asked how do you do it
you should explain you know I was so
nervous during this game I I can't
explain at some point because I um I've
played a lot of games against Richard
where he out plays me in this sort of
style and uh and also I felt the
pressure of the tournament situation
like do I play for a win but I don't
want to take huge risks of course
because uh the worst thing is to lose uh
and and to miss out on everything but of
course lenier maybe let's say he gets
some winning chances I also have to
watch out for that so I had a lot of
thoughts going through my head and
around this
moment uh like I started to feel like
I've been getting outplayed and I
thought he would just take on C3 or
something and okay it's probably equal I
mean in many cases but then when he
allowed this Knight E4 suddenly I
started to get very optimistic MH
because I thought okay now Knight D6 is
an idea um he was hoping for some
tactics but I didn't see exactly how
they're working okay I always have to be
careful for Knight E3 and yeah then I
was thinking okay C5 is very sharp
because if Knight C5 Knight D3 something
happens I don't know what so somewhere
around this moment linear finished his
game right so what were your thoughts at
this at this time yeah no I was still
thinking okay let's um let's not go
crazy or anything uh of course yeah the
worst is that is that I lose and and
miss out also on a playoff or against
ler but already at this moment I felt
like I'm out of risk I thought this end
game there's absolutely no risk for for
white I mean uh like worst case he
equalizes somehow best case he's in
serious danger which is what I felt
because his Knights are very awkward I
always have the option of H3 so if he
goes somewhere like Bishop to A3
suddenly I have um probably H3 at some
moment and uh and also my first
intention was something like H3 Knight
F6 Knight D6 because I thought this
tactic and then I saw that after Knight
C8 he can take Rook C8 this is very
important and I didn't feel like I have
everything but then I have anything so
then I saw this rook dc1 and it really
attracted me because I'm keeping the
option of H6 and KN d 6 but also I'm
threatening C6 so felt very dangerous
here and then he went for this sequence
I wasn't sure here there was like very
tempting Bishop H4 as well um but I
couldn't see the way forward here H3 and
H6 it looks so weird but uh and and then
yeah it's something collapsed in in his
time trouble but it's so difficult to
defend this yeah I mean especially if he
had not so much time with his clock at
this moment um yeah you said that you
felt pressure today and it's me it was
very important game so finally you
reached your goal this is the next one
as you told me a few few days ago now we
have to win the tournament how does it
feel I mean all this well I I actually
remember last year because uh last year
Ali RZA came he won the rapid and Blitz
and he won the singfield cup and he won
the grand chest tour and I remember
thinking this is amazing to like I can't
ever dream of doing this and this year
somehow I managed to do exactly what he
did last inspired you in a way well I
couldn't can't even say inspired because
I couldn't even expect that I would be
able to reach this these Heights but uh
um yeah somehow it all worked out
perfectly yeah and you know this year
you were winning so many events and um
let's say we were just following it on
on the on our screens all the events all
the prizes you have won um what has
changed in your life let's say or your
in your approach to the game that you
think helped you to succeed this year I
I can't really say because at the start
of the year I I had some rough results
some really rough results um in for
example vikin in the American Cup and
and I wasn't feeling like I was playing
so amazing um but somehow things things
worked out I I did start to um work more
than I was like let's say during covid
years um this took a lot of my um
motivation out motivation to work and
also to play and now I I feel like I've
regained it so I'm I really enjoy
working on chess again and I enjoy
playing even with the stress which is of
course always uh there's always a lot of
stress but I I still really enjoy
playing
um and you know sometimes it's like this
you have waves of good or bad um at the
moment I'm going through a period of
good results and hopefully it continues
yeah who who was in your team who was
helping you during this events yeah so I
I've been working here um with a a
player who I've worked for already many
months Gregorio parin so we work very
well together uh he was also with me at
the World Cup and um uh and at the buest
Grand chest Tour event so so we've
already worked for for several months I
don't think it's a secret that I'm
saying this because we've obviously been
seen together and uh yeah he's he's a
he's an excellent chess player also
excellent um understanding of the game
so I I feel like I've benefited from our
work yeah and um now the plans have to
ask you before the candidates
tournaments candidates tournament what
are you going to do what what is the
plan what will be your preparation ah
well this I can't say uh prob first of
all I don't know exactly yet I have some
preliminary plans but nothing really uh
written in
stone but um also I probably wouldn't
want to share all my all my uh training
plans let's say but of course yeah there
there will be plenty of uh preparation
since it's everyone's going to be taking
it super seriously it's a you know it's
a chance of um of a lifetime for many
players and you don't really get many
opportunities to play so it's always a
privilege to be able to play the
candidates but you will not play in vake
so where do you plan to play before the
candidates any any news you know I I am
playing an event in February but but I
don't think I should say because I I
don't know if it's been officially
announced and and I don't know if maybe
the organizers want to to announce it
themselves so I I don't think I should
say this but it will be an interesting
very interesting event in February uh
with many many great players and I'm
looking forward to that and um I don't
know about the plans for maybe the
American Cup next year I don't know
exactly when the dates will be or um or
what the plan is but also maybe that
will be on the cards before the
candidates we'll we'll we'll see I I
really don't know and um yeah I'm not
sure there's there's well coming up very
soon an event in Toronto on planing so
like in one week yeah that's a big one
with uh Magnus Hikaru Ali Reza Maxim uh
ex not back many of the best players in
the world so my last last question like
how are you going to celebrate now I
think really it's time to celebrate yeah
I I'll probably um yeah I'll probably
have a drink
tonight good good good so all the best
for you Fab thank you so much for all
those interviews and for fantastic
playing the tournament congratulations
once again thank you all the best and
we're going back to the
studio thank you Anastasia and once
again a huge congratulations to Fabiano
Carana who is the winner of the sink
field cup and he wins
$100,000 as well as taking the grand
chesto points of 13 lenia Dominguez also
a wild card in second place with
$65,000 to the good and in third place
it was Wesley so taking home
48,000 and how does this all translate
to the Grand chest final standings well
we knew two days ago that Fabiana Carana
was going to be the grand chess tour
champion and he's got the highest ever
score of 46 out of 52 points I think it
was it's something absolutely
magnificent but in second place it was
Maxim Vash lra who collected 28 grand
chest T points and in third place Wesley
so and these prizes include uh the bonus
money of 100,000 for first in the grand
chest tour 50,000 second and
25,000 third yes and this is our
champion and this is our champion
Fabiano caruana singfield Cup champion
Grand test tour Champion St Louis rapid
and blitz winner what a year that
Fabiano has had simply spectacular
simply spectacular glorious for
yourselves for ourselves you Fabby Joy
I'm like wow just wow Joy it's wonderful
uh calling the action with you and Peter
it's just been it's been a lot of fun
thank you guys for me it's been a a
privilege to be calling all the action
alongside you guys sharing your
knowledge and your W I like the bow tie
look I'm telling you you got to go you
got to BR it's not coming back I've
some it was marvelous I like poers that
be are against it really and you you
must you must you know obey by
those the powers that be shot you down
final thoughts on these broadcasts and
what what's I I've heard a fantastic
time here covering both the rapid and
Blitz and the singfield cup but in terms
of what we watched watched Fabby just be
Head and Shoulders above everybody else
both tournaments were very close but
despite all that he still won both
outright and you know combining this
with the kind of a year he had outside
of these two tournaments in St Louis
it's it really brings to mind the best
years of the best players ever right um
fantastic to watch uh and yeah once
again thanks for for having me here
thanks for putting the show on the air
and enjoyed every moment of it
absolutely and also the fact that Fabby
wasn't in trouble in any of his games it
was like just either a smooth easy
sailing draw or as we just saw a smooth
easy sailing Victory wow yeah what can
we say about Fabby I mean what a
performance he put in today and hold on
I got to I I got to put you on the spot
and we're going to see you back in 2024
you promise to come back I promise to
come back promise I promise okay loving
I never break my word either thank you
for joining us I hope you've enjoyed the
grand chest tour 2023 we will be back
for the grand chest T 2024 I hope
they're streaming the gala uh because
that will be a very very nice event and
until we meet again yep guys it's been a
privilege I'd also like to thank the
production crew and absolutely everyone
involved and also last but not least I'd
like to thank everyone at home for being
part of this journey and watching every
move of the way until the next goodbye
wonderful see you then goodbye
[Music]
everyone
a
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited